e
being late uh before we get started uh
representative gon would you like to
please okay I'm going to open up the
public hearing on House Bill
758 establishing a committee to study
airport operation
second is the prime sponsor of
Representative Dupont or anybody uh
that's a sponsor of the
bill seeing done as a typical courtesy
can I get somebody to introduce the bill
thank you Mr chairman uh representative
Seth Miller uh straford 21 introducing
House Bill 758 to establish a committee
to study airport operation hours and
provides duties there too uh this bill
establishes a committee to study airport
operation hours it is made up of members
of the house and the Senate um um and
their duties shall include but not be
limited to study how to create a noise
abatement measures for airport operation
hours in the state of New Hampshire and
identify the appropriate Federal
authorities to carry out such an
abatement the study should explore
whether New Hampshire should consider
prohibiting airplane flights from
departing New Hampshire airports between
the hours of 12:00 a.m. and 6:00 a.m. it
should examine the advantages and
disadvantages of such a Prohibition and
involve discussions with relative
stakeholders thank you very much sir y
uh the only person that signed up to
speak again reminder if you want to sign
up to speak to this use one of the pink
cards to sign in for or against use the
blue sheet up front uh next up chair
recognizes without taking a position on
the bill representing the Hampshire
Department of Transportation Bureau of
aeronics is it uh
Lambert is it uh well I'll wait till you
get
sorry about that it's Tuesday not
Monday um I came today just can I just
get you to introduce yourself represent
Trisha Lambert I'm the administrator for
the Bureau of Aeronautics and I'm here
just to provide um technical information
for this bill I know it's just for a
committee um should it come to pass
we're happy to um assist with that
process when if it comes to be
I just wanted to bring forward I guess
two points for this bill um the airports
in the there are 25 open to the public
airports within the state 12 of them are
federally
funded um this um committee if
established would look at closure of
that airport between 12 and 6 12 and
6:00
a.m. there are 12 airports that receive
federal funds that have Grant insurances
that require them to be open during that
time without any type of um impact on
that um and I guess the second point
would be is that majority of your goods
come in at during those hours um for
cargo in the case of Manchester it is
the third largest cargo airport in New
England and that would curtail those
operations and they would have to figure
out something different because they
typically come in during that time frame
so um I guess I'll leave it at that um
it is a committee so we're happy to
assist in the future if if that's what
we need to do thank you thank you I just
have one question for you mind um
currently what's the process for looking
at all mitigation because I I live in
Manchester I've seen you know
neighborhoods around the airports get
all new windows and HVAC systems I mean
there's obviously something already in
place there there was a program they
called a noise noise abatement program
and Manchester was certainly um a big um
participant in that especially in the
2000s um what we have is what they call
a noise contour and it's based on the
type of airplanes that fly in and out of
that airport and what it creates is a
contour and wherever that lies upon the
ground was their determination on who
gets what so if you were within a higher
decibel you would get certain um work
done on your house to help mitigate that
and then as you work your way out from
that Center you would get maybe
something less and then and I do
recognize there were some people that
would say with a line cross my neighbor
got it but I didn't and so but it it's
based off those contour lines but who
oversaw that that's my question that is
the airport sponsor in this case I think
we're talking is Manchester and would be
the FAA would make that final
determination on the funding for that
thank you very much anybody else from
the committee represent guys thank you
Mr chair thank you ma'am so you said
that we have 12 uh federally funded a
airports and that they have to operate
in the hours that are federally funded
that's correct if we did something like
a noise AB bment the restricted flight
would that be overridden by the federal
or would they stop funding that
airport um funding is always could be an
issue going forward but the bigger issue
is going to be if they curtail those
operations the federal government can
come back in and say that we want our
money back and they do it on a pration
basis thank you ma'am anybody else
represent
H thank you Mr chair uh thank you for
being here thank um I apologize up front
I I'm not aware of your Committee of who
you represent can you speak to uh your
Bureau what it is you do and sure
appreciate that um our Bureau um is a
small Bureau of eight full-time we are
pretty much everything for Aviation
within the state we are the fa
liaison all the funds federal funds that
flow through to this to those airports
go through our office and they call that
a channel we're a channeling State um we
are also a block rant state so for some
of those smaller airports we act as the
FAA for those airports in that funding
so we do the planning programming um and
we oversee the grants that go out to the
airports for the engineering and
development work um we do collect some
Revenue through uh the aircraft
registration program which is
essentially like the DMV but for for
airplanes uh we are respond to aircraft
accidents and support the FAA and NTSB
when those occur so we will have
somebody an inspector on the ground for
that um we currently many of you may see
in the news we run the Alton Bay ice
Runway um and that's anywhere from a
week to 20 weeks 10 weeks
um and anything else that relates to to
um Aviation
whether it's um Homeland Security
Aviation assets those types of things
thank you you're welcome repres
SES thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um you did you
referred to Freight operations as
possibly being impacted I wondered how
this bill would affect uh EAS uh funding
for central air service funding from the
feds thank you for the question uh
the only the airport in the state that
currently I believe gets AAS funding is
Lebanon I don't know that they operate
outside those hours Short of coming in
um late you know not on time um I'd have
to look that up to see whether they
actually oper come in after
midnight and this bill is just to
establish a commission so anybody else
from the
committee seeing done thank you very
much you're welcome thank you having
nobody else signed to speak on this bill
I'm going to close the public hearing on
House Bill
758 couple of minutes to reset we'll go
correct this is we
got
year it's got to
okay I'm gonna open up the public
emergency allowing voluntary emergency
workers to use rear-facing blue lights
on their private Vehicles when involved
in emergency
service uh chair recognizes to repres uh
to introduce the bill
representative now
leano um obviously in support of the
bill you do have written testimony and
you don't need a whole five minutes I'm
sure but I'm I'm I'm sure I won't I've
got to be at another another committee
meeting so I'll make it uh brief um good
morning uh chairman Walsh Vice chairman
Gorski and members of the transportation
committee
thank you for your time today my name is
Rich Nano and I represent Cheshire
District 9 which includes the towns of
elad Gilson Marlo and Stoddard I'm here
to introduce House Bill 489 as the prime
sponsor House Bill 489 is a
straightforward necessary minor
amendment to existing legislation which
is RSA 266 colon 78- B Roman numeral
3 uh to ensure that our emergency Merc
responders have the necessary tools they
need to do their job safely and
effectively a few years ago RSA 266 78b
was amended to allow a single
rear-facing blue light on ambulances and
fire trucks while well-intentioned and
necessary that addition to the law
inadvertently created an inconsistency
one that HB 489 seeks to correct House
Bill 489 ensures that all First
Responders operating a vehicle during an
emergency whether the vehicle is
publicly or privately owned have clear
and consistent visibility improving
safety for both First Responders and the
general public to be clear this bill
costs the state and towns nothing
volunteer emergency Personnel typically
pay for their own emergency lights and
this legislation only allows the option
for a rear-facing blue light and does
not mandate that anyone purchase and
install one what H Bill H House Bill 489
does is correct an over sight in the
existing law supporting this bill means
uh supporting our fire firefighters and
Emergency Management workers and
volunteers the very men and women we all
rely on to respond in emergency
situations visibility especially during
emergencies matters especially on New
Hampshire's roads where conditions can
be unpredictable and I would add to the
written testimony that that's especially
true in rural parts of the state where I
live you take a road like 123 and
everybody has ever traversed 123 which
I'm doing daily you have real issues if
there's an accident or something on the
roadway you come upon it around a Bend
pretty uh
suddenly H 489 is a simple Common Sense
solution that ensures that emergency
responders can be seen protected and
able to do their jobs as safely as
possible I urge this committee to
support a recommendation of autop pass
for house
49 thank you on behalf of all the
emergency responders in our state I I'd
add to that uh I want to personally uh
be in a position to thank everybody that
volunteers for these important jobs uh
it's getting harder and harder to
attract Volunteers in our state and we
need to do everything within our power
to make sure that they have the
necessary tools protection and uh other
things that they need to do their jobs
for all of us um respectfully submitted
for your consideration and I've given
copies enough I think for everybody on
the committee um I also have with me
today and I think he's going to testify
or be available for questions um Gordon
Kemp who uh is on both our emergency
ambulance Corps and uh the fire
department in elad so thank you very
much again for and if you have any
questions for me I'll be glad to take
take them thank you sir and thank you
for reading your testimony to us uh any
questions from the committee
representative Miller thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative for
your testimony um in reviewing the
existing uh text of the legislation in
advance of the session I note there's a
section that says when the blue colored
lights are installed on a private
vehicle owned by or leased to a law
enforcement officer such light shall be
covered when the vehicle is being driven
by someone other than a law enforcement
officer
uh in that this bill would allow a
similar situation where these lights
would be installed on a vehicle not
owned by the city or state so it's a
private vehicle but would be driven by
not a law enforcement officer would you
expect that they would also be covered
when it's not being driven by the
volunteer who might be using that or
we'll just leave it turned off and
that's probably sufficient well I think
it could either be turned off I mean the
fact that the lights there and uh you to
be turned off or I think are you saying
if the person is not involved in the
emergency
situation I my read of this is like if a
police officer has this on a leased
vehicle on their private car and their
spouse is driving it it is supposed to
be covered rather than visible I'm not
sure that actually ever happens or as
practical but that's what the law says
and so I'm curious if that you think
this would apply there as well yeah I I
I think it would generally not be turned
on okay fa so thank
you any other questions from the
committee represent thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative for
taking my question uh for clarification
so why is it a blue light that's being
requested not a red light I know there's
already a red light in the existing law
right uh is it 27 26678 C um so in your
testimony here it says for firefighters
EMS but so doesn't that already exist
and what's the clarification on that
well I think it doesn't what this is
intended to do is to cover uh volunteers
that AR necessarily covered under this
uh legislation but I do have Mr km who
is here with me that can probably uh
answer that
question more wait well you can either
wait or I don't know what the procedure
is if it helps a few years back we
passed a law that enabled fire to use
the blue light which was against what we
had currently this is just adding
volunteers it's really just anybody else
from the
committee it's just a very short
addition if you look at the existing
legislation and it I think it's pretty
straightforward and I I believe
basically it's a common sense U addition
to the existing
legislation anybody else being then
thank you very much thank
you and with great
fanfair chair recognizes Gordon KMP
representing himself in support of the
morning chairman members of the
committee thank you for your time and
allowing me to testify before you this
morning my name is Gordon Kemp I'm a
selectman in alad uh licensed emergency
medical responder member of Alid
ambulance and a firefighter with Alid
and aworth fire departments um I think
representative Neno covered most
everything I was going to say I don't
want to take up more time so um I think
what I'll do is just answer any
questions if if you have
any thank you very much sir any
questions from the
committee representative St
Clair thank you Mr chair and thank you
and I'm not trying to be smart about
this or anything
but you think that blue lights get more
respect than red
lights no sir I don't it's not about
respect at all it's um when this
legislation was amended in
2015 it was there was testimony offered
about this science behind blue lights
cutting through inclement weather fog
snow and things like that uh much better
than red and also blue lights being
better um at night um similarly uh the
law enforcement was allowed you to start
using red lights recently for you know
the flip side of
that thank you anybody else from the
committee representative pondon thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question um kind of along the same lines
my concern is blue lights are inherently
for law enforcement and I know this
visibility issue but would you be
amenable to uh red and and blue red and
yellow for a higher visibility even read
in and Amber you know a uh like a clear
lens for for the visibility my concern
is the public is
inherently uh accustomed to being blue
being there's law enforcement present
not knowing if arms are are drawn or
what the situation is whereas uh red is
denotes fire ambulance uh and so on so I
re I fully support the visibility issue
uh just exclusively blue personally I uh
I'm not sure how I feel about that can
you elaborate more on other color
options instead of exclusive L
blue so thank you for your question
um so to be clear this is only adding a
single rear-facing blue light that would
be an addition to um red lights that are
already in use um and it's my
understanding the law requires 360
degree visibility of emergency lights so
both the sides in the front would be red
and I believe you can use Amber as well
it's only on the rear and a single light
and you know you know no fire no
volunteers are going to show up with you
know a a full side or the whole rear or
the whole front you know flashing blue
it's just a single small light on the
rear um to attract attention and cut
through the Clutter and cut through um
inclement weather uh it's it's the exact
same reason why we do it on the fire
trucks and ambulances currently those
are all red and Amber and white and then
light for the question
see thank you very much sir thank you uh
next up chair recogniz is Matt Uchi
represented New Hampshire State
Police in opposition to the bill welcome
sir morning Mr chair morning committee
members uh my name is m mitui uh I'm
here in opposition of this bill on
behalf of the New Hampshire State
Police um we view this as a public
safety concern the primary reason for
restricting blue lights to emergency
vehicles is to Main maintain Public
Safety and Trust increasing the amount
of blue lights on our roadways will lead
to misidentification and confusion from
the public historically blue lights uh
have been reserved for law enforcement
and first responder
vehicles uh although there are some fire
trucks and ambulances with a rear-facing
blue light there is no confusion as to
what those vehicles
are um blue lights on private Vehicles
will lead to confusion and desensitize
the public to blue lights
so with that I'll GL to answer any
questions thank you sir questions from
the
committee seeing
n representative Miller
sorry uh thank thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking our questions um
the the vehicles that these would be on
would be Vehicles responding to
emergency situations and albeit not
structured as an emergency vehicle
they're still performing that service
and so I'm curious the the people doing
that arguably deserve the same
protection um that the light visibility
offers where what is the what is the net
negative impact that you see more
broadly of this because these are
emergency responders is it just because
different types of vehicles are used
rather than the people yes thank you for
the question um I think it just
generally desensitizes the public to
Blue Lights um currently when people see
blue lights
they they view that as law enforcement
and although they're on fire trucks and
ambulances those are very distinct
vehicles that you know what those
vehicles are if you put them on any
vehicle that's out there I think over
time it's just going to desensitize the
public to what those those vehicle those
vehicles are um it's just one
rear-facing
um blue light typically when they
respond to scenes there's going to be
fire trucks
ambulances police cars so there'll be
plenty of other vehicles that are there
that will have an assortment of Lights
blue and red um I think just having a
rear-facing blue light on any vehicle um
it'll be hundreds of vehicles throughout
the state I think it will desensitize
just for clarity can
volunteer um fire departments put a
single blue light on the back of their
you anybody else from the committee
seeing n thank you very much sir thank
you okay I have nobody else signed up to
speak on this bill so I'm going to close
the public
hearing uh a few minutes to reset um
yeah
all right good morning everybody or
welcome back I should
say I'm going to open up the public
hearing on H Bill 533 relative to the
use of Civilian employees and commercial
truck
inspections I'm looking in the gallery
and I do not see anybody that's a
sponsor of this bill or prime or I mean
a or Co so as a common courtesy can I
ask somebody to formally introduce the
bill for the
foot thank you Mr chair committee
members I'm here to introduce House Bill
533 relative to the use of Civilian
employees in commercial truck
inspections this bill authorizes
division of State Police to use civilian
automotive equipment inspectors in
certain inspections and authorize any
officer of the Department of Safety or
other law enforcement agent certified to
conduct truck inspections to enter
during regular business hours the
commercial premises owned or leased by a
commercial carrier wherein certain
required records are stored or
maintained for the purpose of conducting
a compliance review new entrance safety
audit or investigation into to inspect
in a reasonable manner the records for
the purpose of enforcing certain
regulations um
this bill is the request of the
Department of Safety and I'm introducing
this as a courtesy for representative
trer thank you sir I I won't ask you if
questions uh let me see eenie
meanie when don't we do this chair
recognizes Bob Scully from New Hampshire
Motor Transport Association doesn't
appear to be taking a position on the
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is Bob
Scully representing New Hampshire Motor
Transport Association um initially I was
going to be opposing this bill there's
been some confusion on our part as to
where these equipment inspectors would
be going to do their work um our history
with civilian employees in the on the
commercial truck side has not been good
particularly when it applies to the uh
CDL application process I have been told
that these inspectors would not be going
to do inspections in the commercial
Motor Vehicle area if that's true we
don't have a position with this bill um
but if it was to be true then I would be
opposing this strongly because we had a
lot of problems with that um we have a
great relationship with the state police
we'd prefer th those employees there
because they understand what they're
doing okay and our folks are used to
them and know what they're talking about
so um at least on the truck side as long
as they're not going there then we don't
have position on this bill for some
reason this was to more for change than
we would oppose it thank you Mr chair
thank you sir take any questions any
questions from the committee seeing none
thank you very much thank
you uh next up chair recognizes car hon
Heston Rec representing the Hampshire
State Police in support of the bill
welcome
sir good morning chairman and members of
the committee I just want to clarify
this the the title is certainly um a
little confusing this this is two
separate um things in one bill so the
first one which is under 2661
a talks about adding the language or
adding the term automotive equipment
inspector uh as an
authorized um person
to help enforce our state's motor
vehicle inspector laws and rules the
second part of this is adding two terms
to a completely separate set of rsas 266
72a which is our Motor Carrier
enforcement uh section and in that
section the the M carrier section it
adds two terms to paragraph D which are
new entrance safety audit and compliance
review and in regards to this we get
audited by the Federal Motor Carrier
safety administration and one of the
findings that they had in regards to our
Motor Carrier enforcement program was
what they deemed right of entry and in
the body of 26672 a sub paragraph D it
allows anybody that's certified to
conduct commercial vehicle
inspections allows them or gives them
permission to enter a motor carrier's
primary place of business during
business hours to examine business
records and conduct an investigation the
Federal Motor Carrier uh Administration
asked us to go even further and to
clarify that somebody could enter
somebody that's certified to conduct
truck inspections can
enter the motor carrier's primary place
of business during business hours to
examine records and to perform a new
entrance safety audit Andor compliance
review um
they're both investigations and for
whatever reason feder Motor Carrier
asked us to include those two terms
because they're two
specific uh activities that we do on
behalf of Federal Motor Carrier so again
the the title and the analysis um not
100% correct and I just wanted to make
sure that everybody here was aware that
they're two separate sections of
266 and there will be no civilians or no
automotive equipment inspectors
conducting commercial motor vehicle
inspections and I will take any
questions if there are any thank you
yeah thank you for that actually I have
to I'm a little confused uh on the first
section in terms of automotive equipment
inspectors I thought we were you were
already doing that we are this this just
adds that title into the section as an
authorized person to do it so how were
you doing it previously without
something in statute because I have to
be honest with you and I'm I'm asking
this because I have heard nothing good
about anybody other than State Police
monitoring the inspection stations they
all walk around with Napoleon attitudes
so how are you doing it
um this adds basically it's it's adding
automotive equipment inspector it's one
of our civilian employees that's
authorized by the director Bo of
vehicles to do
this if that if that makes sense to you
sir kind of I I'll follow up uh my
second question on this was just to
follow up with u Mr Scully um safe to
say that sub paragraph D La enforcement
agent certified to conduct truck
inspections that means it's somebody
from law enforcement correct period
correct it and they would have to have
been trained to do uh commercial vehicle
inspectors which is only uh State Police
in in the state all right so it's not an
equipment inspector authorized by law
enforcement no uh not at all two
completely different things however they
ended up in the same bill just looking
for some clarity thank you very much
thank you anybody else from the
committee represent gski thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Colonel for
taking my question can you El elaborate
a little bit more what's the difference
between a compliance review and a new
entrance safety audit uh thank you for
the question the new entrance safety
audit is for a motor carrier that has re
received a do number within the last 16
months basically a new carrier and the
the new entrance safety audit um as I
call it it's the the warm and fuzzy uh
side of what we do uh there's no
enforcement action taken by us if we
find deficiencies a compliance review is
going in and actually looking for
deficiencies or violations of either
state law or Federal
Regulation sure anybody else repres
London thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question so the way I
understand this even though it's not
mentioned in the body of the
legislation this would authorize
civilian Automotive
inspectors
uh in the rsas as it's in the body
now my understanding is that they would
only um the automotive equipment
inspectors would only be um citing
violations of our administrative rules
if their if through the course of
their working or investigations or
monitoring uh either car dealers or
inspection stations if they find a
violation of law it gets turned over to
one of our Troopers so they will not
they may recognize a violation of state
law but it it is then turned over uh to
somebody from law enforcement to
continue with thank you thank you Mr
chair
is it against the law to violate your
administrative rules it is however in
most instances those results and an
administrative hearing and not uh Court
action thank you anybody else
representative Miller thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking the
question
um who how would the civilians that are
performing this role be sourced for lack
of a better word identified certified
licensed trained it's and
paid for this role who's handling the
budget for that and how are these people
being found trained and then how's the
budget handled for that thank you thank
you for the question they're an employee
a civilian employee of the the Hampshire
State Police so they go through the the
hiring process with us they go through a
training process with us uh both well
both us and the division of motor
vehicles uh all of these automotive
equipment inspectors are also certified
motor vehicle inspectors like your
normal local garage would be so they
they are trained uh and they are hired
through the state police
process anybody
else seeing n thank you very much sir
thank you okay I have nobody else signed
up to speak on this bill so I'm going to
close the public hearing on House Bill
533 we actually not only have caught up
but we are early um 10 10:30 is our next
hearing on House Bill 594 see you
then
e
it being uh 10:32 I like to open up the
uh public hearing on HB
594 relative to the definition of a way
um we don't see the prime sponsor so uh
representative foot will be introducing
it as a courtesy thank you
representative thank you Mr chair
members of the committee I'm here to
Courtesy introduce house bill 94
relative to definition of a way this
bill repeals the alterate definition of
a way for the purposes of driving after
suspension or replication statute this
bill is at the request of the Department
you okay thank you
sir okay chair now like to recognize
representative lion um who opposes the
bill welcome to welcome to
Transportation representative uh thank
you Mr chairman for the record I am
Erica Leon uh represent pres ative for
the town of dairy which is Rockingham 13
and this bill seeks to repeal language
that was passed by this committee last
year in what I like to call the right to
Mo section um prior to passing that bill
if you had your license suspended for
doing bad things like driving under the
influence and you drove a riding lawn
mower in the state you were subject to
seven days in jail because the law
previously didn't differentiate between
driving anywhere in the state and
driving on away this specific language
that's being removed was written with
the intention that if you don't know
where the actual legal edge of your
property is and your lawn goes for feet
further you won't risk spending seven
nights in jail for mowing up to the edge
of your grass um as we worked through
with us and I worked on this bill with
the Department of Motor Vehicles they
didn't see any problems with the
language as it's written however
speaking to um speaking prior to this
meeting it sounds that this could be
interpreted that somebody could drive um
in a demolition derby down the median of
i93 uh without any charges and without
any problems for them driving that way
with a suspended license that was never
my intention of the language and um I
I'm actually going to look to work with
both the Department of Justice and with
the Department of Transportation to
figure out how we can make the language
clear so that you can mow up to the edge
of your lawn even if that is not not
technically your property or perhaps
more importantly the property that you
were mowing as a landscaper while not
allowing demolition derbies in this
Center
median thank you representative any
questions from the committee
representative Hill thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question representative uh is this
strictly about mowing or is it uh is
that euphemistically used uh thank you
for the question um so this was actually
the most challenging section of the law
as we put it together because the
largest time when you would be operating
what is considered a motor vehicle in
the state of New Hampshire with a
suspended license would be mowing your
lawn so that your spouse doesn't have to
do that after you're doing errands
picking up the kids driving you where
you need to go and then they have to
come home and mow um that was one of the
large intentions of the bill previously
uh there was some concern that this that
this language that they're addressing
could mean that somebody could just
drive right on the edge of the property
uh which was never my intention honestly
you wouldn't be you might be oper
creating a tractor on the edge because
you might be using that or an ATV in
order to take your driveway and scrap
back although even that makes me a
little nervous if you're on a pave
service surface I'm a lot more nervous
about that and enabling that in
legislation than I am about making sure
that if you were mowing your property or
the property you're hired to mow um you
aren't risking a week in jail um the
intention is mowing but I also don't
want to write it so narrowly that if
somebody I I just don't want to write it
so narrowly that we have more problems
and need to come back in the
future
followup thank you
um is it is it your belief that um it's
the government that's going to question
where you're mowing or is it a neighbor
or how how did that work I I forget
actually thank you so the law is
currently well the law was on the books
that you could spend you know that you
could get an enhanced um ticket for
driving on a suspend license when mowing
or operating a tractor on your own
property or property or even hired um
the first time it was introduced the
bill was killed because nobody had been
arrested for it but just because nobody
has actually done the time for a crime
doesn't mean that it should be on the
books um right now I actually had the
police called on me for cutting down a
tree that was too that was close to the
road and somebody was worried that we
weren't going to do it in a responsible
manner um there's absolutely the issue
of neighbors have ing on neighbors and
causing headaches and causing problems
um so there's no reason to leave
literally a gray area between somebody's
property boundary and the edge of their
grass um to allow sort of malicious
actions thank you question
representative hembel uh thank you uh Mr
chair and thank you for being here so
just to get something you talk about
somebody on with a suspended license
uh on a lawnmower riding lawn mower
cutting grass on their property which
happens to be you know right away on the
street so they can be arrested for um
driving on the suspended license is that
correct um Pro so let me give you a
little bit more background right now if
you're mowing your lawn and you don't
know your property line is 10 fet back
from the actual Road and you mow that
you're fine you're in the clear because
that's between the edge of your property
and the unimproved edge of the roadway
so right now you would not be arrested
for that and you would not lose your
license for longer and spend a week in
jail this bill if it passes would make
it so that if you don't if you go past
that that legal line of the edge of your
property and go past that on your riding
lawn mower you would risk losing your
license I think for another six months
and spending a week in jail um and I I
did look I'm not sure how many people
know how close their actual property
line is with their edge of their grass
but most people mistaken about where
those edges are follow up follow
up so can my 12 year-old grandson ride
or do go over that line and get arrested
for not having a license that's a great
question if you've never had a license
you don't need a license to operate a
lawn mower um but previous to this to
the the bill that passed last year if
you had a suspended license for a DUI
you can't operate a riding lawn m but if
you've never had a license in your life
or you're not old enough for a license
you can do a you can use a riding lawn
mower it was one of those areas where as
we debate all the details of these bills
we don't always realize the unintended
consequences from our language choices
that one actually goes back to when a
motor vehicle was described as something
with an engine that was operated on a
way and then we recodified our laws in
the 30s and we changed the definition of
way and we didn't change the definition
of Motor Vehicle um so rather than
changing the definition of Motor Vehicle
back to something that's operated on a
way because that has bigger issues um
the the simple idea was that nobody
realized that it was illegal to operate
a lawn mower or a tractor on private
property everybody always thought that
that was just an issue on on on state
roads on ways but that's not what the
law said so I came in last year change
that language so that if you have a
suspended license you're treated the
same as somebody who's never had a
license in operating a lawn mower or a
tractor or another another motor vehicle
um and and this is this this bill today
is one that would make it so that
there's a gray area between your
property and the lawn where you get in a
whole heap of of trouble thank
you any other questions representative
Peto question of the chair um do we have
somebody from the Department of Justice
signed up to speak I do not have any
other pink cards thank you right now
representative J G thank you Mr chair uh
thank you honorable representative
taking the question so my understanding
is that a driver's license gives you
permission to drive on public roadways
and that law enforcement enforces the
rules of public
roadways if is it are you saying that if
this goes through it will revoke the
language that defines a public roadway
and therefore would expand the scope of
Duty for law enforcement to go onto
private properties looking for mowers I
don't think that they ever would but is
that what why this is important um the
reason this is important is because the
way is Def defined as that section from
the edge of one property to another
where a road is a lot of times that
legal way is larger than the actual road
that we think of as the road so because
that is larger than that actual edge of
the road uh this build this section
that's being repealed by this bill only
addresses the operating with a suspended
license with a motor vehicle on that
distance between what's commonly
understood as the road and what's
legally the way but appears to be
private
property any other questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you so
much if I may say one more thing you may
um I will speak with the Department of
Justice Department of Transportation see
if we can come up with something that
makes everybody happy and then bring it
to the committee if that would if that
would be amendable to the committee yes
if you can let uh let the chairman know
or send it to the chairman chairman
Walsh will take that under arisman thank
you representative P pom just one one
quick question and thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking a question is
is my understanding that you're saying
the no one
has received any violations or been been
arrested for this to date we're being
proactive is that what I understand um
yes um then so nobody had been arrested
for that um so I guess we'll do a little
bit of a public service announcement for
people to make good choices on the last
day of session in my first term I went
out after session and was arrested for a
DUI in my driveway um when that happened
you know I deserved it I took all of the
punishment but my husband had punishment
that had to take punishment so he had to
drive the kids he had to do all the
errands he had to drive me where I had
to go he had to go to work and because
my lawyer advised me that you could not
operate a motor vehicle including a
riding lawn mower he had to do all of
that and then come home and mow all of
our grass uh I may be a bit of a special
case because there's some people in town
that like me some people that don't um I
live one and a half miles from the
police station on a major road and
everybody sees me when I'm out in my
yard um I was not willing to be a test
case to be the first person arrested for
that lose my license for another six
months and spend seven nights in jail
away from my young children uh rather
than having the very heavy hand of the
law come down on somebody I thought the
appropriate thing was to change this in
the legislature um I have to say every
time I bring this up I'm ashamed about
what I did but I can't change the past
and I'm not the only person in the state
that's made that mistake so I want to
make sure that I'm standing up for
everybody especially those who
especially those who have made a mistake
and make sure that that all future
proportionate any other questions from
the committee not seeing any thank you
so much thank you not have anybody else
uh here testify I'm going to close the
public hearing on HB
594 our
next bill will be HB 632 at 1050 in
minutes
e
okay it be in
1050 I'd like to open up the public
hearing on HB
632 permitting healthc care providers
affiliated with the Veterans
Administration to certify medical
accommodations on behalf of veterans
residing in New Hampshire chair elog
recognize the prime sponsor
representative gason hello sir thank you
Mr chair thank you honorable members of
the committee so I'm introducing House
Bill
632 uh which which as chair stated
provides the uh provides healthc care
providers affiliated with the VA to
certify medical accommodations
specifically equipment accommodations
for veterans in New Hampshire uh this
basically is to close a loophole that
was that was inadvertently opened up by
the jail car last year uh through safe C
21.8 which read that in order for uh
medical provision or exception to
equipment to be provided that the
healthcare provider provider had to be
an instate licensed healthc care
provider what that did was inadvertently
disqualify Healthcare Providers from the
VA most of which are licensed healthc
care providers in other states who
through Federal contract take an
assignments somewhere so like if you
walk through the Manchester VA most of
those Health Care Providers doctors
nurses Pas Etc they're not licensed in
the state of New Hampshire they're
practicing on their Federal
reciprocity on an assignment here in New
Hampshire um this may not be compliant
with several ADA rules already and so
what this bill does is it resolves that
VA healthc care providers can write
these medical exceptions for equipment
that will be accepted by the
DMV um for for instances of handicap or
instances of medical disability I did
sit with uh director morasco I sat with
the adant general and I sat with the
chief medical officer at the at the
Manchester VA hospital and all three of
them said it would take us less time to
put legislation through to close this
loophole than it would for them to go
through the rules change process um so
it was recommended that we purs pursue
this
legislation um it'll it'll restore the
intent of the law faster than going
through the rules change process and it
will likely keep us out of a major
lawsuit uh pending any questions thank
you sir any questions from the committee
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative gon for being here today
and taking questions
um based on your last question is there
a Financial Risk if we do not pass this
Bill thank you for your question uh
representative yes so uh there are
already a group of veterans that are
talking to each other about uh a lawsuit
possibly a class action lawsuit on the
state of New Hampshire for Ada
non-compliance under three different
articles of federal law uh by the fact
that medical exceptions have started to
be denied the first series of phone
calls that I got this was actually uh
this was submitted to me for draft by a
veteran and then I had several other
veteran phone calls uh to push it
further and basically it started to
manifest when people with eye injuries
or chronic migraines started to get
their windshield tint renewed and the
DMV said we can't authorize that because
your provider is not in state and then
we started looking at where that policy
could be applied and it can be applied
to several other places which is why at
the end of the bill they actually
there's bold lettering there was an
amendment put in to uh to cover all
medical exceptions where it was
originally drafted toward the windshield
tint because that was kind of the low
hanging fruit so my concern is that if
this doesn't get through both bodies and
signed by the governor quickly we would
be facing a lawsuit for Ada
non-compliance thank
you any other questions for the
committee representative
Miller thank you Mr chairman uh
represent guys and thanks for taking my
question um in reading this I just want
to understand is your expectation that a
medical provider uh Associated or
affiliated with the US Department of
Veterans Affairs which is what's written
here um would only be providing this for
veterans or is this something where I as
a practitioner could be doing some work
for the VA and some work in private
practice in Massachusetts
but issue something for a regular
patient who lives in New Hampshire from
my practice in Massachusetts who is not
a veteran if does that make sense it's
sort of a weird I'm looking at edge
cases I know but is that something where
we think this would happen or is this
veterans people at it would be at a va's
location or under VA offices that this
would be granted to Veterans thank you
for the question uh this is specific to
practicing for the VA um whether it's on
a facility or whether it's uh through
contract to the VA at a smaller you know
location or even on site location this
would not be geared toward private
healthcare providers um that would be
that would be something different one of
the reasons that New Hampshire tried to
narrow this down with the healthc care
provider is because each state tracks
their own licenses and while you have
rest prostituted practice in other
places each state tracks its own
licenses so my understanding when this
rule change happened was that they were
trying to lean down invest
investigations for healthc care
providers that are you know maybe tella
Health from Michigan or something and
they just they just missed an accidently
took out the VA it's very easy for the
DMV to call Dr Forest over at the at the
VA hospital and say hey is this person
practicing and licensed it's a lot
harder when you get into private
practices over the borders where we
can't confirm somebody's license in the
event of an
investigation does does that answer your
question sir any other questions a thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question do we need to put a definition
of medical provider in there make sure
it's not I mean LPN can be a licensed
medical provider um do we need to say
physician or you know optometrist or
something along those lines to kind of
narrow the scope of this thank you for
your question um I used the term medical
provider because that term is already
codified into law in the state of New
Hampshire there are laws that say what a
medical provider is what licenses in are
included I stayed away from terms such
as doctor because I did not want to
contest the state's pre-aligned
definition of what a medical provider is
so this isn't going to play differently
with existing
laws follow would it would it be better
to put a reference to that law that
defines medic as defined by RSA blah
I think that we could do that but where
we already have a definition of medical
provider in law I don't know that it
would be
necessary any other questions from the
committee one quick question before I
let you go if this passes does it help
our vets if this bill passes to get
treatment you know more efficiently and
more
effectively yes it does it also helps
our veterans get medical accommodations
um for Disabilities that are recognized
through the V by not having to go pay a
separate private practitioner and you
know many veterans that are using the VA
as their sole healthc care um don't
don't have the money to go hire another
doctor somewhere they're getting that at
that is their health insurance and that
is their health
coverage any other questions from the
committee representative emblem uh thank
you Mr chair uh thank you uh so just
maybe a little clarification so if we
have a retired vet whose primary
residence is New Hampshire
registers their vehicles New Hampshire
Etc but Sunbirds in Florida during the
winter and reive Care from the medical
from the VA in
Florida uh what the VA in Florida says
okay you need this in order to function
in life that is to be recognized here in
New
Hampshire yes it would be any um any VA
Affiliated healthc care provider
treating a citizen of New Hampshire
thank
you any other questions not seeing any
thank you
sir chair I would like to recognize
representative uh Lon uh who is in
support of the bill welcome
back thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee um I'm sorry that we
need to be here today for this bill as a
member of The Joint legislative
committee on administrative rules I was
one of the people that passed this
language that unintentional
discriminated against the VA we are very
limited in what it is that we can do in
jail car looking to our job is to see if
the rules are authorized under the
statutes if they're aligned with the
underlying statutes and then there's a
general public interest Clause um had we
been aware of this at the time we would
have raised the public interest Clause
to also include VA Physicians but um if
you want to look at the schedule that we
have coming up this Friday just listing
the rules that we have is over a page
and some of those are hundreds of pages
long so we rely on other people to find
issues um when necessary um as a side
note I'm hoping that this committee has
somebody looking over the transportation
rules that we are adopting because there
is nothing like experienced eyes who
helped pass the laws to make sure that
the administrative rules do follow the
intention of the the past language um so
in Jael car we generally look to a lot
of things around licensing and I believe
and I wasn't intimately involved with
the bill as it went through but I
believe that there was a question about
whether we want to allow outof State
providers or just inate providers to do
this and to provide this Li this um
certification um I do think um
representative Miller that it may make
sense to talk to people who have been
involved in this and potentially look to
bring a broader bill that would allow
crossborder uh Physicians to write these
permissions but that's outside of the
scope of this existing bill um speaking
to Veterans Administration provid ERS um
if you look at veterans in New Hampshire
they don't just go to the vas that are
in New Hampshire they go to the ones in
Maine they go to the ones in Vermont and
they go to the ones in Massachusetts and
that's if they're residing full-time in
New Hampshire for those who also travel
it's quite likely that they would visit
other vas as well and since everyone who
served wrote a check for everything up
to and including their life I think the
least thing we can do is allow them to
be seen by VA doctors anywhere in the
state and get the accommodations that
they need on their
licenses um speaking to the issue of
medical providers and the definitions
this law is really informing some of the
administrative rules that'll be reopt it
after we pass this law and they are very
comfortable and very familiar with the
definition of medical provider and
linking it to a definition somewhere in
the statutes um wouldn't add any more
transparency or any more helpfulness um
as somebody who served three years on
the Health and Human Services committee
um I realized just how many Medical
providers we have in the state for those
of you who don't know we actually have
Physicians assistants that are sometimes
the senior person on staff at a hospital
up in the North Country so the last
thing I want to do is limit their
ability to make sure that somebody can
get the accommodations that they need um
I do want to thank representative gisan
for bringing this bill um it's
absolutely critical that we update this
and we fix this um once this is done
they'll be able to spe speed through an
emergency rule in Jael car where that
can get get basically put into effect
while they rewrite all of the language
but there's an entire process for
adopting a rule where you need to have
the language which can take months to
get have a public hearing then digest
the information from the public hearing
and then go through the actual approval
process with jel car car even on an easy
change it takes the better part of a
year so I'm hopeful that this committee
will adopt this take it as it's written
pass it through and hopefully we can
encourage our friends on the other side
of the wall to pick this up quickly
so that we can make sure that veterans
are getting the getting the
accommodations that they rightly
deserve thank you so much any questions
from the committee not seeing any thank
you so much thank you chair now i' like
to recognize representative F who's
requesting for two minutes who is in
support of the bill welcome sir the
transportation thank you Mr chair I'm
David Frack representing Grafton 16 the
town of
Enfield um I do support this bill um and
I would posit that there are civilians
non
veterans who if you were
to amend the bill to include providers
from neighboring
states would greatly benefit I'm sure
that there
are
residents along the Connecticut River
Valley the Massachusetts border and the
Maine border who are not affiliated with
a VA hospital because they have never
served the United
States who see a provider in a different
state and as long as we are looking at
this bill focused on Veterans I am
asking the committee to broaden it
slightly and make the same typee of uh
accommodation available to Residents who
seek and have been seeking their health
care from a provider in a neighboring or
ating
State thank you thank you any questions
from committee representative a just to
clarify what you're saying so if
somebody who lives in New Hampshire goes
to Boston and to to seek a
specialist and the specialist says you
need to need to have your window tinted
to you know mitigate your this problem
they would then have to come back to New
Hampshire and find a specialist
here to give them that waiver because
the specialist in Massachusetts is not a
licensed in New Hampshire that would be
the case currently and I'm proposing
that the New Hampshire DMV would be able
to accept the certification from from
the specialist in Boston or the primary
care
in for instance White River
Junction follow up so you know so
another scenario is that usually if you
you live in New Hampshire you have a
primary care position here and then you
you go under the care of a specialist
out of state but they refer you back to
the
your your local
PCP to to issue any order or
prescriptions or well I I would posit
that if I lived in say
Claremont I don't believe Claremont has
a
hospital um and I my primary care was
from Springfield Vermont hospital that
the physician or health care provider
working and licensed at the Springfield
Vermont Hospital could then be off
authorized to provide the
certification perfect thank you any
other questions from the committee not
seeing any thank you so much thank you
for
listening chair now like to recognize
the honorable Warner horn who's asking
for three minutes who's supporting the
transportation thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee for the record
my name is Warner horn and I'm happy to
tell you everything I'm going to say has
already been said so with that I'm in
support of the bill and I'm hopeful that
we can close this Loop inadvertently
open awesome any questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you so
much uh that is the last person I have
that wants to testify on this so I'm
going to close the hearing on HB
632 our next bill would be in in about 5
e
11 I'm going to open up the public
hearing on HP 450 to FN relative to the
issuance of driver's licenses for aliens
temporarily residing in New Hampshire
the chair would like to
recognize representative Walsh welcome
to transport Transportation
sir thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
Tom Walsh I represent marac 10 which are
the towns of hook and
Dunbarton and I am here to introduce uh
House Bill 452 you just mentioned the
title
um I am going unscripted so be gentle on
me I know this is a pretty intimidating
committee to be sitting in front of um a
lot of you that were here last year
probably recognized this bill that
started out as House Bill
1118 which just to get into the bill
itself for a few minutes consisted of
basically lines three
through uh
25 those were just
changes um that were actually put in by
another member of the committee last
year uh dealing with how you get a
license and requirements of the director
of Motor Vehicles on on what shall be
relative information for for his
decision or her decision to give him a
license so those changes are pretty
simple um and again that's lines 3
through 25 uh line 7 talks with
notwithstanding 26340 a which is just a
requirement the social security number
is required in most cases to get a
license um a big change on line 15 prior
and currently
uh because the bill that we passed out
of the house amended uh the original
1118 was interim studied in the Senate
um changes the word from May to shall
previously or currently I should say the
word may still is there and under
certain well depending on who's the
director they may not uh look at any of
the criteria that is spelled out in the
statute for uh getting a driver's
license New Hampshire driver's license
so that word chain a sh
and then you'll see a few changes um on
those requirements that they shall
consider um and a few changes to
lettering because actually C on line 22
was moved into
line 18 uh etc etc so that was the
original
1118 during that whole period we were
also watching the news every night like
everybody else around the country
watching what was going on at our
borders watching the millions of people
coming across the border every day and
we started asking questions of the
department on who's actually getting
dri's licenses in the state of New
Hampshire and we were told
repeatedly the all nobody getting nobody
in a pending case is getting a driver's
license and this went on for months so
okay that's as Fair as it can get it was
later on that we were made aware that oh
well if they get a temporary work
authorization then of course they get a
social security number which means now
they can get an Hampshire driver's
license and that's where the rest of the
bill lines one and two and then lines
26 through the balance of the bill came
on 1118 as an
amendment why would I do this and I'll
get into the details of what it does in
a minute fundamentally for
me I realize and it's in statute that
the ability to drive on the roads of New
Hampshire is a privilege it's not a
right contrary to what a lot of people
say because we don't have uh you know
mass transit and adequate public
transportation it should be everybody's
right to drive and that's not true it
has not been changed driving is a
privilege and I find it very unfair to
the L biting citizens of this country
that we just hand out driver's licenses
to people that are currently claiming
Asylum but have yet had their case
adjudicated in in the immigration courts
so that being said uh Alliance One and
Two start the bill this version of it by
saying that the people that have gotten
gotten their license prior to the change
shall not get it renewed simple
enough and then when you get down to
license uh L
um that's just recognizing that these
licenses will not
be uh used for State voter registration
or any other the purposes related to
local state
Federal
voting on page two of the
bill um I'm just going through
this uh line four is unchanged um line
three is a new section this is where
addressing the asiles um
begins uh that's a new section uh what
it says basically and I don't have to
read it to you uh but what it says is
that people who have claimed Asylum to
get into the country will not not get a
license even if they've been granted a
temporary work authorization until they
have gone through and completed their
court cases through the immigration
courts and become lawful Perman
permanent
citizens I think it's as Fair as it gets
if there was a fairer way to do this I
would look at it but I I can't you
either agree that it's not fair to give
people licenses that haven't even proven
their illegally yet or not and I think
some of the confusion that happened last
year is the the difference between
lawful presence and legally just to give
you a quick one what what goes on at the
border all what had been going on at the
border although it's changed
considerably at this point that anybody
could come regardless of any third party
agreement third safe country
agreements anybody from any country on
the planet was coming up to our Southern
border and claiming
Asylum they they have to go through not
to mention the fact that they were also
helped Along by some NOS I'd be curious
to see how many of that those
organizations were getting money from us
aid but we'll look at that into the
future so they were being en coached on
the process and once they get into a
Port of Entry uh the first thing they go
through is a screening and they have to
answer some basic questions if they
answer those basic questions correctly
uh they're then given an i589 which is a
uh
basically the lawful presence that we
talk about uh it just says you can't be
deported while you're waiting to go
through your Asylum hearings uh and not
once they get to 589 their names
whatever names they were provided get
put into the safe database and then
they're released into the interior of
the country with hopes that they come
back for their hearings of or their
their cases at a at a later
time um that's the nutshell and that's
where the confusion was some people can
say Well they're here legally well I
contend they're not they're here with
lawful presence to prove they're here
legally and so all this bill does is
instead of putting the C before the
horse once you prove and you are here
legally and you are not going to be
asked to leave because you your your
claim is
illegitimate then then you can get a
license not not before then to give them
and just hand out our licenses prior to
proof that you are here legally uh I
don't think it's fair to the citizens
and that's why I put this forward uh
just to be honest with all of you uh
obviously we put this in in November
nobody knew what today was going to look
like last month I was actually
considering do we even still need this
anymore maybe I should withdraw the bill
and then our our our borders are and I
hate that word but uh Tom Holman came
out last month with with a pretty
shattering statistic and after the
research he's been doing and he's
actually been doing this since
1984 estimates that nine out of 10 of
these Asylum claims are
illegitimate that's
90% that's all I needed to hear to keep
this thing in motion and and I'm I'm
hoping that the committee will see
favorably pass it one more time and and
put it to the house floor with that Mr
chair I'll take any
questions okay uh representative Hill
thank you Mr chairman uh quick question
um when someone here that's lawfully
present and applies for Asylum is
denied um what do we do in New Hampshire
um to revoke them license or do we do
anything and does your bill do anything
in that
circumstance I do not know what they do
if they're deported obviously then the
license is negated this bill prevents
them from getting them renewed
specifically but in terms of an actual
mechanism good question maybe it's
something we can look at if they're
denied their Asylum I mean granted they
have to leave wow that's not necessarily
true there's a whole appeal process as
well so until they've exhausted all the
appeals I would I would imagine the
license would still be if they've been
given one still be
valid representative Miller thank you Mr
chairman uh just want to make sure I
understand your position on the
definitions here um you're suggesting
that someone who approaches the Border
claims Asylum through the legal process
established by the federal government is
granted the paperwork is established by
the federal government is in fact not
here
legally it's a semantics it's a play
with words and yes you are right has
been said in the media by our vice
president I believe the to be able to
call somebody here lawfully present
legal is like waving a magic wand you
have to look into the words the the the
document they get the
i589 gives them permission to lawfully
stay here while they're waiting for
their case to be completed um so to me
and you're right that's my opinion when
you see you cannot be deported you're
allowed to stay while you go to your
Asylum case or or hearings to see if you
are here legally and can stay legally
because if you're not then they tell you
you have to go once you go through the
appeals process etc etc thank followup
follow up um with respect specifically
to Driver's Licenses we use them
typically for identification and proof
of I'll say education or qualification
to operate a motor vehicle um is there
any specifics about the person's legal
status in the country that changes
either their identification or their
proof of their ability to operate a
motor vehicle that suggest it needs to
be revoked or not issued say that one
more time I just want to make sure I get
in your full full understand my
understand generally speaking the reason
driver's licenses are issued are twofold
one is they can be used to demonstrate
your identity and two is to demonstrate
that you have satisfied the DMV's
requirements and proof of ability to
safely operate a motor vehicle does
the immigration status of a person alter
either their Identity or their ability
to demonstrate that they can safely
operate a motor vehicle on our roads
which are the purposes of the license
yeah well I'll agree with you on one
thing when when licenses were first
created that's all they were for was to
prove that you had the ability to drive
on the on on this on the roads of New
Hampshire since then obviously they've
been morphed into our identification for
everything and you are right uh things
do change as they go through the process
whether it be an asylum claim or
permanent resident and once you get
permanent residency and a social
security number then you can move on to
applying for citizenship and you're
right I forgot to mention that in the
last part of the bill it does I believe
Roman four uh also add uh that
denotation on the license and that's if
you've got one legally um you know using
some of the parameters on page one in
other
words for the purposes of attending
public education institutions uh lawful
employment uh spous are child of alien
etc etc I hope that answers your
question it did not thank you well I
mean try you can if the chair will
entertain I maybe try to rephrase it a
little different you want to rephrase or
think about it I will try one more time
does the legal status of someone in the
United States affect their ability to
prove that they can safely operate a
motor vehicle per the DMV that was easy
no thank
you representative V thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question um there there are seven
different at least seven different
treaties and international agreements
that govern how Asylum Seekers and
refugees should be treated does this
distinguish between uh a refugee and and
an asylum Seeker because they're two
different definitions but they both have
drawn
processes thank you for the question uh
last year's version did have um refugees
in it and I know that is one of the
things the Senate did not like about it
because it is a whole different it's a
whole different approach or or process I
should say uh generally speaking
refugees or people seeking Refugee
status actually requested in their
country of origin U it's Asylum that
usually happens when well you have to be
on our soil before you can claim Asylum
and just just so you know how how how in
my opinion how abused this whole process
was in the last four years we even heard
from our department of motor vehicles
that even people that we're gracious
enough to give student visas vacation
visas or tourist visas and sometimes
work visas when those visas expired the
previous administration was allowing
people to claim Asylum then you know I
mean I just it everybody should be
outraged on what we saw for the last
four years and this is just a in my
opinion just just a a fair way to deal
with who gets the privilege to drive in
this
state representative
pataro thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um I need to be
brought up to speed I served on the
transportation Committee in 2021 you
mentioned uh hb1 1118 which um you said
is in interim study in the Senate
currently is that the case
they put it thank you for the question
they put an interim Study last term so
essentially it's gone from the Senate
now so just to just to give you an
example the one of the people that had
an issue with the word Refugee in the
previous bill which is one of the
reasons it went to interm study is now a
senate co-sponsor so I believe that the
small changes I made by eliminating
those other two categories or that one
category uh was sufficient enough for
them to move forward with supporting it
follow up Mr
up between 2023 and now has something
changed in New Hampshire where
non-resident aliens can now get New
Hampshire driver's
licenses no the big thing that changed
was the
urgency previous to I don't know if it
was 23 or
22 um the federal government would issue
temporary work authorizations a year
after somebody claimed Asylum through a
Port of Entry then the urgency became
National you remember hearing Governors
across the country who were receiving
large numbers of immigrants were were
pleading with the federal government to
start issuing the temporary work
authorizations sooner we actually had
many bills previous to that that were
supposed to close the gap between the
time when somebody filed for Asylum or
claimed Asylum and waited that year for
uh a temporary work authorization now
keep in mind the only reason we're all
here and even having this discussion is
because we were we were it was allowed
to have millions and millions of people
come across the border this is Pain
self-inflicted by the previous
administration because the system is
overwhelmed and I'll to be honest with
you I don't even want to be doing this
but in in my duty in my opinion to
defend the fairness to the citizens of
this state this is why I'm going to keep
moving forward with this
bill um and the unfortunate side of this
is that yes unfortunately the people
that are here legitimately with
legitimate claims and just so you know
to claim Asylum this is still statute
this is still federal law you need to
prove that anyone with legitimate fear
of persecution based on race religion
political views or membership in a
particular quote unquote social group is
the only reason for legitimate Asylum
seeking a better life is not a reason a
legitimate reason to claim asylum in the
United States so unfortunately the
people that are truly here um under the
the definition of asylum seeking refu
well not Refuge but seeking seeking a
Asylum from these situations they're
caught up in the same system and now
based on the millions of people that
have
overwhelmed the uh the process I hear 8
10 years before some of these people are
going to be getting their day in in
Immigration Court to prove their status
with the prove they're legitimately here
I don't know if that helps but
tremendously thank you yeah
representative
Sykes yeah thank you Mr chairman uh
Walsh do you have any um inkling of how
many people in the last you you are
correct that it takes 10 years perhaps
to get your hearing do you have any uh
knowledge of the numbers of as siles
over the last 10 years who are currently
driving and supporting their families
would be
affected by this
bill I do not represent PES and it's
unfortunate they may be caught up in
this whole thing but once again this is
situation
follow representa G thank you Mr chair
representative Walsh thank you for
taking the question it's probably going
to be the easiest one um
so this would not change the way that
New Hampshire um acknowledges idps or
International driving permits for
tourists correct
correct representative hemam uh thank
you Mr chair thank you representative
Walch uh Ju Just on something entirely
different on page two lines 19 and
20 um it says the driver's license card
shall bear a mark in indicating that
it's not resident a driver's license um
there's nothing that defines what kind
of market so is there anything currently
on the books that would define something
like this or is this something that the
director of the DMV would say put a
little black dot on the back of the
license when nobody notices
it under RSA 541a under rules the
department could establish what that
symbol looks like thank
you representative p command thank you
Mr chair and thank you representative
wall for taking the question I'm just
curious whether this is a really a
national issue I do you know of any
other states that have introduced
similar uh
DMVs originally when I did my research I
looked at what other states are doing I
don't know that they're similar but yes
there are many states that have been
doing so things to address the same Pro
the same problem specifically I don't
have those in front of me but yes I
believe it or not one of the most
extreme ones I saw was a little State
called Iowa and I was surprised to see
they had one of the strictest proposed
bills dealing with licenses um and
they're not even technically on the
borders of our country so yes it's all
over the
country any other questions from the
committee not oh representative
Miller one last followup I may uh you
mentioned uh subsequent to our previous
my prior questions uh keeping things
Fair uh for residents of the State of
New Hampshire citizens
um is what is unfair about someone who
is who has proven their ability to
safely operate a motor vehicle doing so
regardless of their
citizenship as I said it is a privilege
that the state of New Hampshire citizens
hold dear and have to comply with all
the laws that they do we have two bills
specifically that are trying to take
that away to keep that license I don't
think it's fair that if you
intentionally mislead or lie to get into
this country based on an asylum claim
that you know is not correct or not true
to get that same privilege period that
is why I'm doing this I am standing up
for the people of the State uh it's
unfortunate that the legitimate ases may
get caught up in this thing but but I'm
sorry if you said any untruths at your
hearings or said any untruths to claim
that you're an asy here even if you
don't meet this definition that has been
in law for years then you are complicit
and I don't think you should get the
privilege to drive in this
state
followup who gets to decide and when
whether that lie or misstatement was
made I told you they have to go through
the immigration courts which
unfortunately because of the millions of
applications is years in delay and so I
I I'm not going to take a position that
just for the sake of a few uh legitimate
ones we should give everybody one I
don't think that's fair uh unfortunately
the legitimate ones are going to get
caught up waiting for the ones that
aren't thank you any other questions
from the committee not seeing any thank
you sir thank you and we can discuss
this more at the executive session we
will be doing it today I assume we
will chair and now like to recognize
representative bataki how' I do
great he's asking for four to five
minutes he uh opposes the bill um he
does have written testimony that he'll
provide welcome C Transportation thank
you uh Mr chair ranking member and
committee
members uh my name is shaj budathoki I
represent hillsbor County District 40 I
came here to strongly oppose HB 452 not
just as a legislator but as someone who
understands firsthand what it means to
come to this country seeking a better
life 16 years ago I arrived in the
United States as Refugee after spending
nearly 20 two decades in a refugee camp
I'm always thankful and humbled for the
support I was
given I know what it is like to start
over in a new country to work hard to
rebuild alive from nothing and I know
how I and I know that something as
simple as driver's license can mean the
difference between opportunity and
struggle this bill targets people who
are here legally students workers
families people who are trying to do
right thing it tells them that no matter
how hard they work how much they
contribute or How Deeply they want to be
part of this state they are not welcome
that's not the New Hampshire I know
denying someone a driver's license
doesn't stop them from needing to get to
work or take their kids to school it
just makes their lives harder it forces
them into impossible choices either risk
driving without a license or lose their
job their education their future that is
not Public Safety that is not fairness
that is not who we are and let's talk
about who this build effects it punishes
ases people who have fled War
persecution and unimaginable hardships
by saying they must wait years for their
status to adjust before they can even
drive legally it punishes students who
come here to learn workers who come here
to feel critical labor shortages and the
spouses and children of those who have
already here already been granted
permission to be here I want to remind
this chamber that when I arrived in this
country I had nothing but because this
country gave me a chance because I was
able to work to study and yes to drive I
now stand before you as a state
representative a business owner and a
father raising my children in their in
this great state this bill would take
that opportunity away from people who
just want to do what I did work hard and
contribute to society
and let's be clear this bill does not
make our roads safe safer in fact it
does the opposite when people are denied
a driver's license they are also denied
the ability to tested to get tested
insured and held accountable under the
law this bill would create more
unlicensed uninsured drivers on our
roads this is not Public Safety this is
reckless New Hampshire has always always
been a place that values hard work and
fairness this bill goes against both it
punishes the very people who want to
follow the law who want to contribute
and who want to be part of our
communities I urge my colleagues look
beyond the politics thank you the about
think about the real people this bill
would hurt I know because I was one of
them what know on this Bill thank you
thank you sir any questions from the
committee representative Hill thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for taking my
question um you say that people want to
come here and and follow the law and yet
you're saying that they um if this bill
were to pass that they will break the
law and and I'm wondering if you can um
resolve that dilemma I have for those
two issues so
so here we're talking about people who
came here here legally like refugees
ases and then when they're here you know
well vered and why we not giving
opportunity to apply for D license and
get tested and drive in our roads so I
think it is straightforward when they're
here legally we should give them
license any other questions from the
committee representative stclair thank
you Mr chair thank you
representative do you have any idea just
a if the numbers are out there of how
many people that now have their
license uh but have not achieved the
final goal uh when they're not allowed
to renew their license what kind of
numbers are we talking about any any
idea I don't have number representative
at this time I don't
know I would ask follow well with you
um is that something that we could
possibly get from the Department of
Motor Vehicles I mean they must have
some sort of handle on that I would
think we can try to reach out and see we
have nobody here from the DMV
so thank
you go ahead repres if I could be of
assistance in this question um in
previous years the testimony from DMV
has been that there are approximately
um
15,000 driver licenses that are
non-resident aliens as described by this
bill who who are driving in this state
now and how many of those would be
affected probably is unknown but we are
talking about many many many people not
just a few handful
do that
satisfy it does for the time thank you P
any other questions from the committee
not seeing any thank you sir and you
have written testimony if you can get
that to the clerk we'd appreciate
it chair I like to recognize Jessica
asenta she's asking for about five
minutes opposing the bill and has some
written testimony welcome to uh
transportation
good morning my name is Jessica peler
and I am the legal director of asentria
community services immigration legal
assistance program asentria Care
Alliance is a 150y old Health and Human
Services nonprofit with over 75 years of
experience resettling refugees in New
Hampshire through bipartisan us Refugee
admissions programs we help legally
admitted admitted refugees integrate
into their community ities secure
employment and Achieve
self-sufficiency I and we are deeply
concerned that HB 452 creates
unnecessary barriers to employment
economic participation and Community
integration for legally present
individuals section three of HB 452
prohibits the issuance of driver's
license to Ayes until theyve become
lawful permanent residents regardless of
their legal employment authorization
document card this restriction is not
only unne necessary but harmful ases
have already been granted protection by
an immigration judge making them legally
authorized to work eligible for a social
security number and to pay taxes under
US immigration law asiles must wait at
least one year before applying for
lawful permanent residency or their
Green Card currently US citizenship and
Immigration Services takes an additional
14.5 months to process these
applications meaning that for more than
two years after receiving Asylum status
asiles would be prevented from driving
under this bill denying them a driver's
license would severely limit their
ability to support themselves and their
families access essential services and
contribute to the state's economy ases
differ from refugees in that they seek
protection after arriving in the United
States they may add students tourists
businessmen or Parolees like the many
Afghans who've placed the lives on their
line for our country and now proudly
call the gr at State home to qualify
they must meet the legal definition of a
refugee and undergo extensive vetting
like refugees asiles are individuals who
have fled their home countries to escape
conflict violence or persecution and
have sought safety in the United States
under current New Hampshire law a valid
EAD is required to obtain a driver's
license asiles are legally authorized to
work meaning they should continue to be
eligible given that only 3% of New
Hampshire residents use public
transportation driving is not a luxury
but a necessity for accessing employment
healthare and education restrict
restricting access to driver's license
would make it harder for these
individuals to support themselves and
integrate into the communities the
individuals we serve are not
undocumented immigrants they are legally
recognized thoroughly vetted and on a
path to permanent residency and eventual
citizenship HB 452 though perhaps well
intended cast too wide a net penalizing
individuals following the legal process
to build their lives in the Granite
State this harms individuals and weakens
the state's Workforce and economy thank
you for your consideration I would also
like to say in regard to the previous
statements um that the driver's licenses
can't be used for voting and that the
issuance of the Eads is based on federal
agency standards and that the state
would not have the ability to restrict
that um the bill also says asy so it's
already been determined by an
immigration judge or Asylum hearing
officer that a person has been approved
on their claim and they also as during
that process have been background
checked and vetted um also the i589
previously referred to is the actual
Asylum application it is not a separate
document that either confers some sort
of confirmation that the claim is
recognized or not recognized um prior to
that the person seeking entry into the
United States is given what's called a
credible fear interview and if they pass
that they are allowed to go into the
United States um but they are still in
removal proceedings and must still
approve their Asylum claim also for the
purposes of refugee and asy it is the
same legal standard it's just that one
occurs in a third country outside of the
United States and for an asy it occurs
in the United States and I'm open to any
questioning any questions from the
committee representative
Crawford thank you Mr chairman could you
tell me you made the statement that um
they cannot use that license for voting
how would a ballot clerk know that if it
was presented to
them I don't know what your ballot
Clerk's standards would be for that but
but the presence of the uh driver's
license is as previously stated by
representative Miller used to determine
whether or not they can safely operate a
motor vehicle um so I don't think their
status in the United States is
reflective of
that okay thank you representative
V thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um I assume that
something like this would pretty quickly
trigger lawsuits it if it went went into
effect has this been adjudicated in any
other state have any of the states tried
to do this and and had the case heard in
court and what was the result to my
knowledge No in fact the um Iowa bill is
a proposed Bill similar to the bill that
we have here it would immediately um
be subject to a lawsuit by other um
organizations um for the sheer fact that
the rules governing it are federal rules
and those Federal rules would Trump the
state
rules representative Hill
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question and coming before us
today um you mentioned an extensive
background check in vetting process can
you explain that to
me yes uh there is a Biometrics a series
of Biometrics information that uh
refugees and asiles have to uh submit to
and then that is cross referenced and
checked across several other government
agencies there are seven in total but
including uh Department of Homeland
Security um ATF I can get you the entire
list but there are seven different
agencies that will background check um
in both the United States and uh the
person's Home Country to see whether or
not there have been convictions and even
during the asy process and the refugee
process you have to disclose not only if
you were convicted of a crime but also
if you were ever charged with a crime if
you've ever committed if you've ever
committed a crime for which you've never
been charged so there are variety of
different questions that go into that
and again the determination that stated
previously um with if someone presented
a case of fraud where their claim wasn't
the that is within the purview of the
Asylum judge um which again is a federal
agency
position paa thank you um through that
process if if anything pops up um then
what
happens if something were to pop up
during that time it would be brought up
during that Asylum hearing um the person
would not be granted Asylum or if for
some reason could be granted a
withholding of removal um but it would
absolutely be brought up during that
removal hearing because even though the
person is claiming Asylum it's a
defensive Asylum and it's still a
removal proceeding the government is
still moving to remove that person so
that absolutely would come up and the
Department of Homeland Security um we
call them acc's um assistant um ACC
assistant chief counsels um they would
have access to that and they would put
it on the record during that
hearing one more followup thank you does
that mean that they are not able to stay
are they deported at that point what
happens then it depends it depends on
the fact and Circumstance of each case
um you could have your Asylum claim
denied but depending on what happened in
that previous country you could be
subject to what's called a withholding
of removal from the convention Against
torture or just a withholding of removal
so the way that it looks on the record
is that you're removable but they
withhold it based on something that's
happened but it's unlikely if you had
like say I terrorism gang related
charges drug offenses
um in your home country that that would
be something that they wouldn't remove
removable representative hblm uh thank
you Mr chair uh thank you for being here
today so um as I listen to you and read
your uh testimony is your position that
driver's licensees are very important to
these people Etc um in which I
understand what you're saying and
everything uh just a hypothetical um say
someone had a licensed person in that
status had a license and they were
stopped by the police for an O oui
charge and they were to lose their
license they have the
same
hypothetical um uh hardships so would it
be your position they cannot lose their
license for
oi no person who is uh charged with an
oui would still be subject to the state
laws of if if anyone is charged with an
oui and you have your license removed
for a period of time it doesn't revoke
their employment authorization document
card because there's two separate
determinations um so a person who is
charged regardless of their legal status
um in the United States would still be
subject to having their license um
removed for that for whatever period of
time is already prescribed um under the
state
laws regardless of the hardship would
cause them it would it would certainly
cause them a hardship however I believe
that that's a balancing that the
legislature has between the safety to
the community and um you know their
ability to operate because as previously
stated it's not a right to have a
driver's license but a privilege um
however there are certain standards that
govern the issuing of that license in
the first place it doesn't mean that the
license can't be suspended for whatever
period of time or reinstated after the
period of suspension is over thank you
representative Sykes
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I I just want to uh
drill down a little bit to some previous
testimony
um previous testimony suggested that
nine out of 10 ases were uh not here not
we're we're not telling the truth C can
you confirm or give further explanation
about that statistic because I I find it
I I just want
I cannot give any Credence to that I can
tell you that unrepresented individuals
who go before immigration judges are
significantly less likely to uh Prevail
on their Asylum claims and that is due
to a multiplicity of factors um not the
foremost being it is a quad it is not
the same the Immigration Court that
they're proceeding it is a federal
agency Court um so it is not the same as
an article three court which is what
everyone is familiar with it's
established by the United States
Constitution be it a federal or a state
court um but there are still rules of
procedure and evidence that are required
during that time and legal standards
that govern whether or not Asylum can be
granted and your average Asylum Seeker
uh with no legal background isn't privy
to those cases or the case law that they
should be arguing um so ones that F ones
that have uh legal represented Council
are more likely to succeed but I cannot
say at all that there's any Credence to
uh the statement that nine out of 10 are
fraudulent or in some way false they may
not Prevail but that could be based on
any number of other um
instances thank you representative
pataro thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my
question is a non-resident alien the
alien it depends on how you want to
describe it when you say illegal alien
the word alien is something that is used
used in federal statutes to describe a
person uh who has not who is not a US
citizen um
so nonresident alien I would suppose um
for the purposes of this bill could be
anyone who
um does not have their US citizenship
that I think is the best way that I
could describe it we we tend not to use
the word um illegal alien when we're
talking um in our agency about
individuals uh because they're people
and
because a person's immigration status is
so subject to fluctuation and change for
example with the employment
authorization document cards you can
have more than one employment
authorization document card for more
than one category all of the EAD cards
have category codes on them that list
what your lawful status is so for
example a lot of the Afghan citizens uh
that we assisted have an initial
humanitarian parole category code
because they were paroled in for
humanitarian purposes then also
Afghanistan is listed as a temporary
protected status country by Congress so
you can have an EAD card for that
category temporary protected status you
can also have one and also um I just
wanted to say uh just to correct a point
that Ayes are entitled after 180 days to
apply for the EAD cards it's not after
one year um so
the term illegal alien not non-resident
alien I don't think it really gets to
the status of a person that you're
trying to categorize followup Mr chair
followup uh thank you for that very
thorough answer I really do appreciate
it my followup
is does asentria represent only refugees
and Ayes but not illegal
aliens again I I would I would ask for
your definition of what an legal alien
is the bill talks about a nonresident
alien do you so once again does the
centria represent refugees and Ayes but
not non-resident
aliens um I'm very very sorry I don't
mean I'm not trying to be obstructionist
I just want a clarification of what um
the differing terms are um so so do I
thank you yes sorry thank you um yes we
represent refugees ases we have people
that are here on on student visas we
have people that are um people who marry
US citizen spouses or you know people
that have green cards and then they need
to adjust and get those as well um we
have people who are currently in o r
custody if they're unaccompanied Refugee
minors if a child crosses uh the border
into the United States and they are not
in the company of a guardian or parent
they are placed in o r custody the
office of refugee resettlement because
they are a child they are under the age
of 18 they are transferred to um what is
called o custody and then they get
placed in say long-term foster care
placements so if that child requires
legal services to get an EAD card um
then we help them that way Mr chair one
more followup followup um thank you
again for that thorough answer and um uh
as a side note um I I do like and
appreciate I'm hearing from the work you
do with the different groups of people
you mentioned a group
people people looking to get
married are they non-resident
aliens according to the definition I
would suppose that it would be a
non-resident alien if but they're not
necessarily Asylum or Refugee Seekers
correct but they are present legally
they are getting married to or already
married to a United States citizen and
they might be pending their Green Card a
conditional Green Card sometimes you can
get uh that lasts for two years and the
you have to petition to get those
conditions removed uh but according to
the bill as it's written yes that person
would fall into that category and may
not be able to get a driver's license in
New Hampshire thank you thank you so
much representative Au thank you Mr
chairman thank you again for taking my
question um I think what if I can
restate what you're what maybe you're
getting at is just somebody who came
into the country without making any
contact with immigration
or any kind of service then no
all the people that we represent have
been in contact with either ice Customs
and Border Patrol a federal agent or
someone of that way it's it's and it's
not even the case that a person who and
what we call enter without inspection or
E let's say someone entered without
inspection and was never caught by
border patrol or by Ice they are not
entitled to an EAD card there has to be
some sort of basis for them to get that
work authorization document card and
that's when you would see people working
without authorization
um anywhere across the United
States any other questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you oh
representative
Ryan I'm not sure if this is in your
purview but my son married a woman from
Columbia um it took her it took us 10
years for to get her
citizenship um she did get a green card
um would she not be allowed to get a
driver's license now under this uh under
this bill if she doesn't have her green
card then um she wouldn't be able to get
a driver's license under the bill okay
thank you any other questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you so
much and you're right about your
prediction when you out down 10 minutes
origin was I really it's probably more
like 20 but thank you so much thank you
so much thank you so much shair now like
to recognize Bill
gallette from is it utilities of New
England The International Institute
International Institute of New England
um asking for two minutes who opposes
the Bill thank you sir welcome to
Transportation thank you and thank you
members of the committee for the
opportunity um I will be very brief
because I think you've already had uh
extensive testimony or I know you've
already had extensive testimony on this
and I think it's been very thorough uh
I'd just like to make two points uh and
by the way uh we are a refugee
resettlement organization an immigrant
support organization uh very similar to
what asentria does here in the state um
and we've been in the state since
1980 uh the two points I would like to
make are these the first one is when
someone has work authorization here uh
they should be able to get to work they
should be able to take advantage of the
opportunity that New Hampshire provides
to them uh and I'm concerned that the
way the bill is drafted it's very
unclear who's actually entitled it to a
driver's license let me talk about
non-resident aliens um if a non-resident
alien is anyone who doesn't have a green
card or citizenship then we've got a
very problematic definition because we
have people in the State uh refugees are
a good example and as indicated two
years of vetting outside of the country
before they come here uh as well as AES
and by the way there's a definitional
issue here I think as well an ay
generally speaking of someone who has
been granted Asylum as opposed to an
asylum
Seeker um but that doesn't mean when you
are an asylum Seeker that you are
unlawfully in the country or don't have
authorization to be here but once you
are an asy and once you've been granted
Asylum by a Immigration Court you are on
a path to citizenship now it can take up
to a year or wait you have up to a year
to apply for a green card and then the
Green Card application can take up to
two years so that means you are lawfully
in the country you are fully authorized
to be here fully authorized to work but
you have to wait three years for a
driver's license uh and that does not
make any sense to me I also don't think
that we would consider for example
refugees and ases here as temporary
residents because they have the right to
be here
permanently pending the full and lengthy
application
process uh and that's basically all I
have I think you've heard everything
else I will also recommend to you a
letter from the New Hampshire
immigration rights network uh that is
very detailed very extensive and I think
quite accurate thank you thank you sir
representative Au thank you Mr chairman
thank you taking my question um how
do how do asy Asylum Seekers and um
refugees decide where to go in the
country are they assigned a place or do
they say I want to go to New Hampshire
or do they have a choice the refugee
program is a formal program through the
State Department um when uh people have
have been through the betting process uh
with unhcr overseas uh and the state
department accepts people they then uh
basically determine across the country
where refugees are going to go and there
are 10 National agencies that deal with
uh two or 300 local agencies so for
example we deal with one of those a
national agencies uscri we will tell
them at the beginning of the year what
we think the capacity is for our site in
terms of what housing is available what
our staff is you know what staff is
available what we can do they'll assign
us a number of refugees and then during
the year as people become eligible
having been through the process state
department will and then uscri will say
okay you know Manchester for example
you're going to get these five families
um they determine that based on family
reunification uh similar um basically
communities where where they won't be
for example the only person coming from
their country in that Community but also
to make sure that we don't overwhelm any
Community with uh Refugee with any
particular group once a refugee is here
in the country legally however they can
determine where they want to go if they
have a relative in California they can
go to California or they can stay here
uh and as many of them
do followup thank you um so could this
bill be perceived as trying to say to
the state department don't settle any
any refugees or siles here essentially
trying to cut off their responsibility
and put put the pressure on other states
that would have to take the ases that
aren't necessarily welcome here through
through this well there there aren't
states that have to take them other than
every state I mean just like any person
any citizen in the US you can move to
any state you want um this bill in my
opinion only uh would uh dis
incent significant groups of lawfully
admitted immigrants to be in the state
and making it harder for them to
work any other questions from the
committee representative pataro thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question
um uh The International Institute that
you represent uh it's primarily focused
on refugees and Asylum Seekers and to s
in New
Hampshire well we're in new we also
operate in Massachusetts but yes in New
Hampshire and our primary function is
refugees but we offer job training job
placement esol courses uh and those are
open to other authorized
immigrants follow up please follow up
um is there a path for a refugee from A
to B from Refugee your case to getting a
New Hampshire driver's
license uh since a refugee is legally
admitted uh they are eligible for should
be eligible for a New Hampshire driver's
license when they arrive assuming that
they go through the appropriate testing
um this bill is very vague in that
regard in terms of what they consider a
non-resident alien one more followup
followup um and I know it's not your
expertise but any comments to the same
question in regards to Asylum Seekers or
ases uh certainly an asy has a full
right to be here and is on a path to
citizenship uh it seems to me this bill
would prevent them from getting a
driver's license until they get
permanent resident status which as I
mentioned could take up to three
years thank you any other questions from
the
committee not seeing any thank you sir
thank you with that I have no other pink
cards so I'm going to close the hearing
on HP
452 it's about 12:05 we are going to get
together I believe at 2:00 for exec
session at 2 o'cl so um I assume
there'll be caucuses for the Republicans
we'll be caucusing roughly at about
let's get together about
110 uh for Democrats we'll get
Z
e
executive uh before we get started we
have a couple substitutes today I'd like
to thank for being here representative
Ryan thank you very much welcome to
transportation and Deputy speaker
Smith what if our name plaes wrong have
they been wrong all day oh no you
switched by the way you look weird over
Transportation okay without further Ado
um going to open up the executive
session on House Bill
209 allowing a new vehicle purchased in
the model year or before to be inspected
in the second year after purchas chair
recognizes representative Gorski for a
motion thank you Mr chair uh my motion
for 209 is to
retain motion is to retain 209 is there
a second yes seconded by representative
gas care to speak to your motion sir I
do thank you um 209 I think um has some
great merits however uh the main Prime
sponsor still wants to kind of work on
it and some things to kind of iron out
and he thinks with more time he can make
the Bild better
based on that that's why I think we
should
retain a recommendation of the Prime
sponsor to retain anybody else from the
committee representative
a thank you um I have supported this
bill in the past I was actually a
co-sponsor on it last time it came
through uh but I I do agree that there
probably should be some guardrails uh
beyond what this bill contains and I'd
like to give representative Coker some
time to work on it and come up with
those those guard rails fair enough
anybody else
CN allow the clerk to call the role when
she's ready the motion on 209 is to
retain uh Vice chairman Gorski yes clerk
votes yes representative Hill yes
representative
foot yes representative
Peto yes representative Smith yes
representative G yes representative
Hamlin yes representative
Sykes yes representative
Sinclair yes representative
Fox yes representative ve yes
representative Ryan Yes representative
pendon yes representative Miller yes and
chairman Walsh yes 16 to zero okay we by
the motion of retain to hold on to this
bill is adopted 160 I'll close the
executive session House Bill
209 uh next up we will take up 430 give
okay I'm going to open up the executive
session on House Bill
439 relative to non- driving related
violations and driver's license
suspension chair recognizes
representative V for a motion thank you
Mr chairman I move that we retain HB
439 motion is to retain is there a
second seconded by representative Miller
can to speak to your motion sir yes
thank you
um I I really like this bill in
principle but I think that there are
some problems with some of the
definitions and some of the the language
that um I really don't have a correct
the correct language yet and I'd like
some time to work it out and you know I
think there's some some some people on
the committee that would like to help me
with that so um just like to take this
time and uh make a what I think is a
good bill
better thank you sir anybody else from
the
committee seeing none I'll ask the clerk
to call the rooll when she's ready the
439 chairman Gorski
yes clerk votes yes representative Hill
yes representative foot yes repres
representative terara yes representative
Smith yes representative G yes
representative Hamlin yes representative
syes yes representative Sinclair yes
representative Fox yes representative a
yes representative Ryan Yes
representative Pon yes representative
Miller yes and chairman Walsh yes 16 to
zero all right a motion of retain is
adopted
160 I'll close the executive session on
House Bill 3
439 um next up we'll just go on order
okay going to open up the executive
session on House Bill
452 relative to the issuance of driver's
licenses for aliens temporarily residing
in New Hampshire chair recognizes
representative pataro for a
motion thank you Mr chair I move ought
to pass on HB 452 FN motion's out to
pass is there a second second seconded
by representative Gorski I'll uh I'll
speak to your motion representative
pataro briefly actually seeing as how I
just got through my public hearing on
this this morning so it should be pretty
fresh but just in summary uh I don't
believe this is a controversial bill I
believe it's actually a common sense and
aair Bill I think it's
straightforward just to refresh
everybody's memory this makes some
simple changes to the existing statutes
regarding who can get a New Hampshire
driver's license and the new paragraphs
in there deal with the asylum
Seekers only again I heard the rest of
the hearing after I was done testifying
a lot of the conversation was around
refugees which this bill does not deal
with that's a completely different
situation uh those people apply in their
country of origin um also not mentioned
and not not dealt with in this bill is
uh um humanitarian Parolees they are
also not part of this bill passing this
bill does not affect anybody here on an
education where a student vacation
tourist or work visa nothing of nothing
in this these changes apply to
them as I said in summary it's just I
don't believe fair to the L biting
citizens of the State of New Hampshire
who do what they can to preserve their
privilege to see this privilege given to
others who have not proven that they are
here legally yet it really is that
simple if there were other if there was
another way to do this without getting
the people that actually are doing it
the right way or our legitimate siles I
would entertain it but I couldn't find
another way to make the separation so
again my testimony with you is fresh
I'll leave it at that um I would hope
the committee would support and ought to
committee represent saying
clear thank you Mr chair my my only
concern which I
mentioned off the mic is uh how many
people this would affect that have their
licenses now that have gone by the rules
such as they were and are uh and all of
a sudden be told that they can't renew
their license when they in fact have
been playing by the rules that were set
up and how that will negatively affect
them with regards to uh potentially
employment uh Etc that that's that's a
concern for me and I if we weren't
executing that this today I was hoping
to get numbers from somebody to say how
many potential people that would
affect thank
you fair enough uh but again we get down
to what is playing by the rules have
those people even if they've been here a
long time pursued their Asylum hearings
in Immigration courts we we don't
know
yep granted but we but we also heard how
long it takes to get through the process
so I heard numbers up to 10 years which
is crazy and I don't see that improving
so again it these people are put in a
hell of a spot uh waiting for the system
to churn them through so to speak so
thank you yeah and I won't go back and
forth with everyone but just remind
everybody I said in the hearing it's
unfortunate we're in this situation the
only reason it's taking 8 to 10 years is
because of the overwhelming at the order
and I it's hard to believe that anybody
wouldn't have known that the system we
had in place wasn't going to get
overwhelmed anybody else from the
committee representative B thank you Mr
chairman um according to the
Constitution immigration is the purview
of the federal government and um this
would attempt to overrule the federal
government and it would violate at least
seven different International agreements
and treaties um I don't think
it's it's it's a lawsuit magnet I I
don't think this is something we're you
know looking forward to trying to
inforce um so for that reason I have to
oppose
this fair enough anybody else from the
committee representative
Miller thank you Mr chairman um you you
just said it's a common sense fair and
simple bill and I think
it I could understand seeing it that way
but I strongly disagree among other
things um to representative St Clair's
point about trying to renew a license um
and people who play by the rules uh line
three the new paragraph added uh Roman
numeral three the department shall not
renew a driver's license for any person
who is not a United States citizen and
cannot prove that they are lawful per
permanent resident of the United States
the fact that there's an and there is a
problem um moreover someone who has
arrived in this country uh as a
temporary worker on a work visa from a
foreign country has had their license
issued and is still here some years
later still on a work visa and needs to
renew their license would be precluded
based on this because it explicitly says
the license shall not renew for any
person who's not a United States citizen
and cannot prove that they are lawful
permanent resident I understand that you
might not want that to be the case but
as I read it I believe that's how it
would be enforced um moreover there's a
section here that describes uh election
related rules and that came up uh during
the conversation the Q&A uh earlier in
the testimony I also serve as a
moderator uh for elections and have
significant experience with the
registration process and checking voter
IDs uh someone who wants to register as
a voter must present proof of
citizenship uh to be able to do so this
does not do that um and as effective as
of last November just after the general
election with the new rules took Effect
one can no longer affidavit citizenship
and so the section of this bill that
talks about using these licenses and
needing to have a special marker some
sort of uh distinction because related
to election law is entirely Superfluous
it does not have any impact there
because that person would not have been
able to register to vote lacking
citizenship and the inability to
affidavit that um that situation um
finally I would note um and we have
talked a little bit about this in the
Q&A earlier about the folks being able
to get to work this bill ultimately
removes people who are un under federal
law able to work legally in the United
States it removes them from the
workforce in New Hampshire um oftentimes
these are people doing things like
health aids or other generally speaking
underpaid for the level of service they
provide work um these are people that we
will have a very difficult time
replacing in our Workforce and you are
now telling them that they will no
longer have access to means to get to
their job uh to help all of us who need
it and um
I I'm going to stop there I could say a
lot more but I'm going to stop there and
say for all of those reasons I uh
encourage that this bill not move
forward anybody else from the
so new
paragraph says that you can't renew a
license for any person who is blah blah
so renew that happens at 5 years I
believe then
26340 a for issuance of licenses covers
non-resident aliens are there a lot of
cases where non-resident aliens are
working in New Hampshire for six seven
or eight years cuz they would be the
only people
of I'm not sure good yeah I'm unaware of
a Visa program that lets somebody work
here for 10 years so I'm not sure who
would be affected by that at all
um thank you for that anybody else from
the
it's actually helpful to have the
hearing in the exact section on the same
day uh without seeing anybody any other
discussion I'll ask the clerk to call
with the rule when she's ready the
452 Vice chairman Gorski yes clerk votes
yes representative Hill yes
representative foot yes representative
pataro yes representative Smith yes
representative G yes representative
Hamlin yes representative Sykes
no representative Sinclair no
representative Fox no representative a
no representative Ryan no Representative
pondon no representative Miller no and
yes
nine seven seven committee
recommendation of to pass is adopted 9
to7 regular calendar it to go I'll close
the executive session on House Bill
452 time for a reset minority oh
Minority Report yes Mr chairman there
will be a Minority Report yet not yet
and and there will be a debate on the
floor
excuse me we GNA open up the executive
session on House Bill
649 removing the requirements for
physical safety inspections and onboard
diagnostic test for passenger vehicles
and eliminating funding for the motor
vehicle air pollution abatement fund
chair recognizes representative gon for
a motion I move ought to pass on House
Bill 649 motions ought to pass is there
a second second seconded by
representative Hill care to speak your
motion sir yes sir thank you Mr chair
so we have gotten all kinds of
testimonies dozens dozens even hundreds
of emails to my account specifically
talking about how uh civilians have had
the had advantage taken of them this is
not a requirement in most other states
um there's 11 states that do safety
inspections as we know it 17 states that
do um some form of emissions testing uh
what we do is not emissions testing it's
an engine code read and uh I even asked
the gentleman during committee um you
know if there was anything that could
throw your engine light on that would
not change emissions and he said no but
I know as a fact and as a mechanical
student that a loose gas cap will throw
an engine light and will not change your
emissions that a bad uh cam position
sensor or a bad electrical wire will do
that the um the onboard diagnostics
reads Electronics further we've had a
lot of uh testimony that people that
don't know cars very well or have been
taken advantage of uh again this is this
is the only good or service that I can
think of where if you don't buy it on
the private Market the state identifies
itself as a victim and levies a fine
there's no other place in New Hampshire
code of law that I've been able to find
that so we've created a mandatory Market
to the vendors which is not the purpose
of this government and it doesn't
actually absolve the driver of liability
for their equipment it gives a false
security thank you sir anybody else from
the
committee representative thank you Mr
chairman um I agree that that there are
a lot of problems with the the uh
inspection program as it is um but I
don't know if I'm quite ready to go so
far as to eliminate the whole thing you
know sarily um I you know for example I
would like to see if it makes sense to
separate the emissions testing from the
safety inspection part of it um
so while I'm not ready to vote OTP for
this I would support retaining it and
bringing it back after we've answered
more questions and
s thank you Mr chairman so um yeah I I
was uh in support of retaining House
Bill 209 because there are questions
that have been legitimately raised and
it is certainly within the perview of of
us as a policy committee to take a look
at those things and try and uh do the
right thing for the citizens of the
state and and that includes safety
issues as well as you know um the that
the inspection
program uh is an important component of
in my opinion um I also think it's very
important to realize that for those of
us who are not mechanically
inclined I being one of them um it's
it's I I find that there's I usually
have a chance to interface with my
mechanic if I notice something which is
rare because I not mechanically inclined
or at inspection time and he I believe
correctly points out um when something
needs to be done uh I
think I have asked for and not as of yet
have not received the data to know about
how many complaints are actually being
made we have we have tweaked the law
recently in uh in in this uh committee
to try and make it possible for people
to who have feel AG grieved by the
process to be uh
notify uh the the state that they are
they are grieved and that there's a
chance for the Troopers to take a look
at the inspection program and so on and
I think we've we've taken some good
steps in the right direction
I I think the proper course of action
for for this committee would be to at
the at the very least retain and
preferably itl it and make one bill the
right bill as opposed to having two
bills essentially talking about the same
topic that may potentially run into
conflict with each other um down the
road a piece in terms of the legislative
process so uh for that reason and others
I would vote against the OTP and and
would would support a retain retained
Bill status where we could as a
committee put the two concepts together
and work and make it one good bill
instead of
forward anybody else in the committee
let me go around the room first
representative Gorski thank you Mr
chairman you for me I've always been a
supporter of the inspection program
however
recently the amount of mail I've gotten
from my constituents regarding this
program has been
overwhelming to say we got to get rid of
it and I mean when I say overwhelming I
good 90 to 95% of my constituents have
said that they want this particular
program gone and I'm here to represent
my constituent even though I kind of
feel somewhat strongly about the program
so that's why I'm going to be voting
OTP um for this particular
Bill anybody else representative Miller
thank you Mr chairman
um I also am inclined to think that our
uh safety inspection program certainly
has its flaws and has potential to be uh
replaced or removed um at the same time
I think I have some of the same concerns
as representative Sykes and Vu who uh
and some of the things we heard during
the testimony specifically
around killing this and potentially
finding ourselves uh in non-compliance
with the EPA um and the funding
associated with that which I understand
there's no guarantee that it disappears
there's no guarantee that we have an EPA
by the time this takes effect but that
notwithstanding uh we are talking about
potentially hundreds of millions of
dollars in do fund on that I think is
irresponsible to put at risk when we
have the opportunity to relatively
easily put a clause in that allows that
to that allows the change to be timed or
structured such that it is in
conjunction with the epa's approval and
so I I also received a lot of the
feedback that all of us did I think via
email um I think that the of the people
that I engaged with in a dialogue about
it uh understand that there is that risk
in play um and even the uh gentleman who
testified with us uh as along with the
prime sponsor uh sent an email noting
that he understood the risks associated
with that and the potential to separate
out the emissions from the in safety
inspection portion of this and the uh
value that could provide and offered to
join a subcommittee
um and work with us to help refine the
bill to get it to something that is in
fact uh good for our constituents and
still allows us to meet our obligations
uh Vis emissions to the federal
government and so in that sense uh a
subcommittee or retain uh would be my
suggestion as
well anybody else represent
pandon thank you Mr
chair I too have concerns with this and
and I agree in in the people I've spoken
to and
mechanics to quote some of them um I
think we have created a monster and I do
think we do need to look at our
inspection process um but I want more
information uh like possibly separating
emissions not losing jeopardizing
Federal monies uh I've have questions on
the citizen inspectors because I've
heard complaints from garages uh
regarding them
um I think we need to simplify our
inspection proc process it's very
convoluted now and uh you know maybe
even something where there's a
possibility for a second opinion for
those a challenge rejection uh to my
understand I think the state gets $15
per inspection so maybe something like a
second opinion minus the $15 and the
garage gets the balance just something
to look at so having said all that I
would support retaining so we could try
to wrap our rounds around this beast and
uh and and get get a process that isn't
just going to blow it up entirely thank
you Mr chair anybody else representative
tyo thank you Mr chair um I did talk to
uh some some constituents and people I
know in the subject area yeah the I want
to Echo what uh our vice chair said like
it's overwhelming overwhelming support
to get rid of our inspection program I
anybody else rips on foot thank you Mr
chairman uh just to Echo what's already
been said so uh like Vice chairman gski
said so personally I I think it's a good
idea to keep it just for personal um
safety concerns by have but also has
spoken to mechanics and uh constituents
and whatnot so based on that
overwhelming response that I've received
personally in my my local constituents
in my town um you know I I would move
forward with passing this so thank
you representative St
Clair thank you Mr chair um I've made my
thoughts on this
situation as long as I've been here in
transportation however um I think if we
do pass this and somehow it gets through
uh that and you correct me if I'm wrong
Mr chair I don't think this would
preclude us from another bill coming
forward to
uh perhaps reinstate the emissions under
uh different you know another Bild to
bring the emissions back U and have it
tweaked so that it's uh maybe better
than what we've got now I just just a
thought I'm not
sure not not this year I'm talking about
whenever
sorry I wasn't even on uh anybody else
second nobody else second bite represent
guys thank you Mr chair so one of the
reasons that I've uh I've been kind of
attached to the idea of getting rid of
this program you know people have said
it needs to be tailored back that's true
but I've talked with uh several members
this of this committee that you know far
predate me and when guardrails had
attempted to be put in place through
this body um they were not put in place
um to the point where
vehicles are being rejected for things
like accessory lighting yeah not
headlights not brake lights not turn
signals accessory lighting um we have
gotten so far away from safety by people
being able to write their own safe C
codes and rules either through jail car
or just through prudent application of
the law that the only way to put a good
program in place in my opinion is to get
rid of this entire program and either
decide that we need to start over with
new guard rails or decide that like the
other 39 States this is nothing more
than pushing money into the private
Market under the threat of
government anybody
else second representative Miller uh
just one last point to representative St
Clair's idea of uh passing this now and
coming back with a new bill later to fix
things um there's an old yish stting
that I probably shouldn't repeat uh in
public but uh it it's a nice dream that
that would work I would I think we would
be it would be more responsible to uh
make adjustments in a way that we know
that we're not destroying the situation
and not having a chance and and hoping
that we can fix it later rather fix it
time representative pondon thank you Mr
chair very briefly just a reminder
should this pass it puts safety
inspections on the shoulders of our
police police are underand and overwork
police and and State Police who they can
look at the surface of the vehicle but
they're not going to be able to check
brakes and so on but that it's it's
going to be on the law enforcement to
check safety issues thank
you anybody
else I'll give you a third bite
represent
gon I respectfully think that that's not
the case in other states that have no
inspection laws the police are not
expected to be um anything beyond their
scope of Duty of incident inspectors and
me having a birthday of February 6th if
I have an accident right now and there's
a suspicion that there is bad equipment
it's not because of my safety inspection
from last year it's because there's
suspicion of bad equipment um I can tell
you if you get pulled over in Kansas the
police are not going underneath your car
to check your brake pads they are doing
the same walk around that they do here
for your safety and theirs they're
applying the the application of the law
and in a post accident that's a post-
accident investigation that is totally
separate from a vehicle inspection so it
police represent St Clair your name was
mentioned go ahead thank you um I want
to assure everybody um that should this
inspection um disappear that if anything
when you going to get an oil change or
get a light change because most of the
vehicles now you cannot change light
bulbs on your own without special tools
that the service stations or dealerships
will be in fact looking for other things
to inform you that hey by the way I'm
underneath your vehicle uh to get the
oil pan out or whatever and I've noticed
that your frame has got some Rust over
here we definitely should be looking at
it your brake pads don't look good this
this whatever even even the the quick
quick oil change places are constantly
looking at stuff that they can sell you
and I get that and so I don't think
that's going to disappear if anything
it'll increase and uh that will help
people uh know about the stuff that
they're being told now thank
you anybody
else all right seeing that I'm just
going to say something briefly on it
having the um benefit
or the benefit of dealing with this for
12 years I get three words open up my my
my thoughts on this enough is enough for
12 years I've been defending this
program for 12 years we've been seeking
all the negative impacts uh that that
might happen if we get rid of the
program including how many Highway funds
we might be getting and we have never
gotten an answer three years ago
actually in 2018 we first started
looking at putting the reasons for
failure into statute by dealing with
rust from what I understand that still
hasn't been updated in the Gordon Derby
system and I'm hearing people still are
getting failed for R issues even though
we put it in statute last year we
decided to take a handful of simple
things that we all agree bipartisanly
that shouldn't be reason for failure and
what happened it was met with resistance
to its Ultimate Death I told people
three years ago we either going to make
people hate this less or you're going to
lose my support for it and I'll start
doing everything I can to see it
repealed here we are now on ter in terms
of the rules we've mentioned that I
forgot the to bring them in but I do
have a set in my desk they are literally
over a quarter inch thick on 8 1/2 by 11
sheets of paper in print that you need a
a magnifying glass to read that's what
this program has turned into and if this
does disappear if this does make it
through this committee and the house and
the Senate and get a signature if it
ever needed to come back in the future
if we saw all of a sudden data
miraculously occur or come out of
existence that yeah I guess it did make
a difference well then maybe the next in
uh um uh inspection program doesn't have
RSA 541a attached to it and that any
reason for failure in the future will be
in statute not in a encyclopedia that
deals with this one topic for that I
will be supporting and ought to pass and
I ask the committee to do the same that
being said I'll ask the clerk to call
the rule when she's ready the motion is
Vice chairman gski yes the clerk votes
no representative Hill yes
representative foot yes representative
Peto yes representative Smith yes
representative gon yes representative
Hamlin no representative Sykes no
representative Sinclair yes
representative Fox
no representative
Veo no representative Ryan
no Representative pandon no
representative Miller no and chairman
Walsh
yes8 to
eight how did I know that was going to
happen Okay the motion fails a motion
about the pass fails
okay representative
V thank you Mr chairman I move that we
retain HB
649 motions to retain is there a second
I'll second it second by representative
motion wasn't uh just very quickly I
already said why I want to retain it um
just to make sure we're crossing all our
tees and dotting the eyes and not
creating unintended consequences and
that's
it anybody else on the routin
representative pondon yes and to to
clarify um on my point earlier uh
regarding New Hampshire not Kansas and
per uh Sergeant retired Sergeant Chase
from the New Hampshire State Police the
memo he sent us who he did oversee
inspections in New Hampshire
under title 21 chapter 266 enforcement
and unsafe Vehicles would be performed
on a daily basis by Troopers and police
officers and quote so I do think it does
put the burden on our law enforcement to
for safety so that's why we need to look
at this okay so that's your that's your
reasoning for retain yes it is that's my
reason is that is the motion anybody
else on the motion to
retain represent PES
thank you Mr chairman yeah I would urge
the committee to uh support the retain
motion it it it will give us an
opportunity to take a look at some of
the things that everybody's been talking
about and you it may be at the end of
the day that we can't come to a any
better solution than we have to this
point but at least we will have given it
um more more of an effort than um than
we have in the past and I think it's
just I think it's the right thing to do
it's an opportunity possibly to to meld
the two different bills that we've
retained maybe we end up with just a
recommendation of only one bill you know
which can't happen it comes out of
committee with a recommendation to kill
one and keep the other um that that is
not beyond the realm of possibility so I
would urge you all to support
retain anybody else representative gon I
don't think I can support the retain
because with the amount of the people
that we represent not the businesses but
the people that have screamed that they
want this program gone I believe that it
deserves a floor fight for a chance to
get rid of this program I believe it's
that
bad I'll chime in now saying I agree
with you 100% um we've retained one in
case this has a an ill
demise but I would rather see this go to
the full house uh with no recommendation
than to retain two bills on the same
subject I don't see where that makes any
sense I don't know what we're going to
fix of it it seems like we're looking at
retain is a reason to silently kill this
just because some may disagree with it
um I don't see why retaining two
helps that being said I'm going to ask
the clerk to call the role when she's
ready the motion is to retain House Bill
649 can I just ask one question so if we
vote not to retain it then it goes well
then back is not a recommendation no
we'll need one more motion for
itl in another debate and if that
fails then we could then it'll go to the
floor with no recommendation so we're
still one if this fails we're one motion
away from going to the
floor does that help I guess
so I'm not sure doesn't make her happy
no okay okay so the motion is to retain
no oh the
clerk
no representative foot no Representative
pataro no representative Smith no
representative G no representative
Hamlin yes representative Sykes
yes representative Sinclair no
representative Fox yes representative
AO yes representative Ryan Yes
representative pondon yes representative
no
8 okay so the motion to retain fails 8
to8 we've only got one more motion left
Arsenal it's Miller time motion to
itl uh in expedient the legislator has
been moved this Z
second seconded by representative syes I
don't think we have need any further
debate do we all right for to make it
official motion inex speeding to
legislate I'll ask the clerk to call the
role when she's
ready take your time I I know you're on
y
okay Vice chairman Gorski
no clerk votes yes representative Hill
no representative foot no Representative
pataro no representative Smith no
representative gon no representative
Hamlin yes representative Sykes yes
representative Sinclair no
representative Fox yes representative
veu yes representative Ryan Yes
representative pandon yes representative
Miller yes and chairman Walsh
no
a okay so the motion inexperience to
legislate fails 8 to8 with no other
options to our at our disposal this will
go to the floor with no recommendation
I'm sure do I have
a mo what a report in favor
of uh that's up to me to decide what the
motion's going to be on the floor it's
pass let me clarify with our Deputy
speaker because I know we changed some
rules this year when it comes out of
here tide do I get I get to declare the
first motion
correct yes so rather than majority and
minority reports since there are no you
have a statement and support of OTP a
statement and support of itl and you
have to pick which one goes first on the
floor
recommendation so just to clarify that
if I declare that not to pass is going
to be the opening motion the same
parliamentary rules work when we get on
the floor in terms of who speaks first
okay then not to pass will be the motion
so we'll be looking for report for an a
to pass and for an
itl and that'll be an itl from from you
okay all right I'll close the executive
session on House Bill 6
49 that was easy um next need to do not
anything uh next up we'll be getting
7:15
e
all right I'm going to open up the
executive session on House Bill 7115
relative to personal electric vehicles
chair recognizes representative hamler
for
motion and expedient the legislator has
been moved on 7:15 there's there a
second seconded by representative foot
care to speak your motion
sir very briefly thank you uh yes so I
had some problems with this bill um as
far as things such as enforcement on
these uh we're talking about rail Trails
off-roading um are we pulling police
officers off our roads to you know be on
the is BET in the woods you know
monitoring speed how are they going to
do this I also have a problem with the
fact that uh it was recommended in here
that persons 16 years or older have a
license however if you're 15 you don't
not need a license to operate the same
Vehicles so for that I vote
committee representative B
um I completely agree that this is not
in its best form
uh that this bill is unworkable as it is
but I do think we need to have a
definition uh hearing people being
encouraged to PE people who are have
their license suspended for DUI being
encouraged to get one of these vehicles
that go 30 40 50 miles an hour to get
around the law that that kind of bothers
me so I I think we need something this
is definitely not it so I don't know if
we need to how we approach that if we
itl this how can't come back next year
but can we you know how do we if we do
come up with something a better
definition something along those lines
that no you're right I mean you are
right if we do itl it it can't come
back um for the remainder of this term I
was going to suggest myself uh because
even the people testifying to this bill
admitted that it had its issues and
we're hoping that we could turn this
into a study committee and I'm not
turning it into a study committee
because I believe uh they could use the
same bill that that we were going to use
as a template and do an ADH heart
committee without going through the
whole rigma rooll and the whole process
but you do raise money one good question
one good point if we once we itl it it's
done for this term so uh I go ahead so
if we itl it a germine bill that does
this is done for this term but they were
also suggesting a class that doesn't
exist yet that may be being written by a
college among other things if we wanted
to put forward a non-gain bill that
defined what an electric vehicle was and
did not have all of the stuff in this in
your opinion as the chair would that be
different enough that we could do that
though well it would certainly be
different enough that I would ask the
speaker to give us his Blessing On It
ultimately he has the the say on gerain
this um unless you want to chime in on
on but it's a good point it's to me it
seems separate enough um but again I
don't get the final the final say on
that okay the usual I I get $10 for
dispensing this
advice all right so and looking at this
nice a new section I always hate that
but I'm wondering why we didn't
include these changes in
the electric personal assistive Mobility
device chapter I think I got that right
which sounds like oh scooters right now
Segways it's a Segway statute I mean I'm
reading this thing it's about driving on
sidewalks and everything it seems like
it might apply more to that so if you
itl this puppy but then update the epam
statute whatever that is that seems
pretty different to me and you can sell
it you get that if something comes up I
think we have good chances of getting
something introduced so long as it's not
similar anybody else uh on the
inexpedient to legislate motion on
7:15 see I'll ask the clerk to call the
role when she's
ready Vice chairman Gorski yes clerk
votes yes representative Hill yes
representative foot yes representative
Peta yes representative Smith yes
representative G yes representative
Sykes no okay represent Clair
yes representative Fox yes
representative AO yes representative
Ryan Yes representative pandon yes
representative Miller no and chairman
Walsh
yes 14-
two okay our recommendation of
inexpedient to legislate on 7:15 is
adopt at
break can I finish my sentence y okay um
where was
I oh uh
142 we're cusp on whether or not we want
to see consent any motions for consent
any objections to consent you you were
opposing what's your what's your you
going to fight
this no objection to consent if I can
get a motion for consent then that's why
we'll put it
okay consent that is I'll close the
what's
up no no problem I'll close you I'll
7:15
e
okay I'm going to open up the executive
session on House Bill
305 relative to speed and red light
cameras for traffic enforcement chair
recogniz as representative
gon thank you Mr chair I'm going to move
itl on House Bill
305 uh motion is inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 305 is there a
second second seconded by represent pill
can to speak to your motion sir yes sir
thank you Mr chair so we heard about the
implementation of these traffic cameras
for for traffic enforcement and highrisk
intersections Etc um when we were asked
how they would identify the driver one
of the uh one of the comments was
basically using Biometrics technology
that can see who the driver is through
the vehicle uh that would be a pretty
significant change of any other traffic
use at tolls or other areas that would
get into privacy issues um we also heard
that this was to be at no expense to the
state but that there were townships that
are complaining about their tax rate
that could implement it and this is not
going to be an inexpensive program
especially since thirdparty vendors are
not allowed but when you do put in a
third party vendor now you have more of
a privacy concern the way it's written
is just not smart legislation and it it
runs that borderline of diving into
people's
privacy thank you sir anybody else from
the
committee well nothing else to be said
I'll ask the clerk to call the role when
she's ready the motion is inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill
305 Vice chairman Gorski yes clerk votes
yes representative Hill yes
representative foot yes representative
Peto yes representative Smith yes
representative G yes representative
Hamlin yes representative
Sykes yes representative Sinclair yes
representative
Fox no representative a
yes representative Ryan Yes
representative pandan no representative
Miller no and uh chairman Walsh yes okay
three our recommendation of itl is
adopted 13-3 regular calendar it will
go Minority Report on this anybody
I'll let you decide uh let me know
before we leave I'll close the executive
session on House Bill
305 next we'll a few minutes uh we'll
390 our clerk is the best we're ready to
go already I'm I'm going to open up the
executive session on House Bill 390
relative to adding fire retired fire
apparatus to antique vehicle exemptions
Hamlin Mr chair I'd like to make a
motion that this bill ought to pass
thank you sir is there a second seconded
by representative Miller care to speak
to your motion sir thank you uh so when
when fire apparatus as we commonly call
fire trucks uh reach their end end of
life typically 20 years plus uh at that
point they can be retired by a town or a
city uh however these trucks are still
in good condition uh there is a growing
um ground swth not a ground SW but uh
interest out there of people using these
trucks as Collectibles something that
they can put in a collection something
they can use and they like to be able to
use these trucks in parades and
and if if they know that they can buy
one of these trucks in the original
condition and use it for nothing say
parade but a show there'll be more
interest in this being able to buy one
of these from a town and a town can have
a means of being able to uh retire this
truck knowing that it's going to go to a
good cause thank
you thank you anybody else from the
committee representative
be thank you Mr chairman um one of my
favorite things in a parade is seeing
the old fire trucks and I think this
helps people give incentive for people
to preserve them regardless of how old
they are so U I totally support this
Bill thank you anybody else represent
SES yeah one one other aspect to this is
actually will make a more vibrant
Marketplace for used fire apparatus
which will help the taxpayers because um
at least in my day when I was in the
fire department we you couldn't you
couldn't give away all fire trucks
nobody wanted them because there was no
there was just no money in it uh this is
a good thing for that reason
too anybody else seeing none I'll ask
the clerk to call the rooll when she's
ready uh the motion is ought to pass on
House Bill
390 Vice chairman Gorski yes cler votes
yes representative Hill no
representative foot yes representative
Tero
yes representative Smith yes
representative um K yes representative
Hamlin yes representative
Sykes yes representative Sinclair yes
representative Fox yes representative
veu yes representative Ryan Yes
representative pandon yes representative
15 to
one
consent 151
yes our motion about the passes adopted
15 to1 I heard consent no no any
objections the consent no I'll close
consent that is I'll close the executive
session on host Bill
390 last one of the day and they we
considered maybe looking at some of the
others but this is the last one of the
minutes okay I'm going to open up the
I'm going to open up the executive
session on House Bill
419 requiring vehicle headlights to be
on when windshield wipers are also on
pataro thank you Mr chair I move itl on
House Bill 419 motions in expedient to
legislate is there a second
second seconded by representative Gorski
care to speak to your motion
sir uh just real briefly
um this this bill really isn't needed um
I'm not sure what it's trying to address
specifically but
um yeah it's just not needed
now thank you anybody else from
represented pondon thank you Mr chair I
won't be supporting supping itl um the
co-sponsors of this legislation it's
it's it's definitely an intended safety
issue during inclement weather we've
heard comments about clearing bugs off
the windshield it it's not about that um
some of the statistics statistics I have
between 1998 2007 seven states enacted
the same legislation and the multiple
not single vehicle accidents but multi
vehicle accidents during the daytime
plummeted substantially in those seven
states so it's strictly a safety issue
uh it's mainly for older vehicles as you
know newer Vehicles now the headlights
automatically come on um but again it's
just a safety issue and that's the
intention behind this legislation so I
can't support the itail motion thank you
anybody else representative gon thank
you Mr chair my biggest concern with
this law was that or with this bill is
that it didn't address the most
important lights on a vehicle when your
windshield wipers are on and that's your
your tail lights because you're you're
kicking up spray in inclement weather
and the intention was visibility within
1,000 ft but you don't have rear side
visibility without the tail lights on
and that was never in any way addressed
in this bill um in addition to that the
verbiage didn't seem to make it these
conditions or windshield wipers on due
to inclement whether it was these
conditions and windshield wipers on
which could actually have a an adverse
effect on the way the law is interpreted
and
exercised thank you sir anybody else
repr repres St Clair thank you Mr chair
maybe somebody can answer this um is
there a law that says you have to use
raining that's a very good point with
the Advent of rainex there's a lot of
people that probably don't because that
stuff does work well good point Thank
you anybody else representative a
one of the things that I appreci
appreciate about this bill is the
definition of needing your your lights
on when visibility is below a th000 feet
a lot of us especially in in Clement
weather weather would probably have a
hard time judging what 1,000 feet is
this changes that to when you're
headlight when your wipers are on which
is a clear definition uh most of us are
going to use our wipers uh whether we
have rainx on there or not but uh so
that's that's why I'll support the
bill anybody else
I'll just say this oh go ahead represent
hlin uh there was one thing that was
left out of the bill in my opinion and
that was using the delay function on
your vehicle you don't always need your
windi wipers working at full speed when
it's raining out um but this bill does
not address as to whether or not it's
okay to use delay at the slowest speed
thank
you anybody else seeing none and and I I
I where I'm at on it I agree with you
maybe perhaps representative plon this
has changed some statistics and the
states have adopted it but I look at it
this way it's just another thing you can
get pulled over for another violation
another thing for police to do there's a
lot of things that we can do for
safety's purposes that don't require
legislation we have those electronic
Billboards all over our highway system
now this could be addressed very easily
with education repeated education
repeated message from the Department of
Transportation hey it's a good idea to
um use your windshield wipers or your
lights when the windshield wipers are on
I just don't see this rising to the
level of requiring another law and
another reason for citation so I'll be
supporting the itl myself with nobody
else I will ask the clerk to call the
role when she's ready the motion is
inexpedient to legislate those Bill
419 Vice chairman Gorski yes clerk votes
yes representative Hill yes
representative foot yes representative
patara yes representative Smith yes
representative gon yes representative
Hamlin yes representative Sykes no
representative Sinclair yes
representative
Fox
no representative a no representative
Ryan no Representative pandon no
representative Miller nope and chairman
6 12 to no no 10 to 10 to six I'm all
right 106 10
six
yeah okay our recommendation of itl on
419 is adopted 10 to 6 this regular
calendar it will go and do am I
expecting a Minority Report okay up all
right so with that I will close the
419 and um thank you everybody we got
through another day we are officially
done hearing all our house bills we're
in pretty good shape uh we will next
week we'll take a vacation with
everybody
else and we'll I'm going to schedule one
more executive session for March 4th
Tuesday the 4th and that'll
conclude assuming we get through
everything next on the fourth all our
our house bills and then we may have a
little reprieve while we wait for
crossover so that being said uh if you
can give me your reports before you
leave please um that would be a great
help we have copies of the reports if
you want to do them long hand thanks